İyi akşamlar arkadaşlar. 20 Ocak 2025 Pazartesi günü saat 19.30. 56. ders günümüz.
Dersimize başlıyoruz. Kaldığımız yerden devam edeceğiz. Ses ya da görüntüde problem olursa bildirin lütfen değerli arkadaşlar.
Arkadaşlar en son String Stream sınıflarını gördük. Genel konu başlığımız Iostream kütüphanesiydi.
Ben Iostream kütüphanesi derken her ne kadar farklı başlık dosyalarına görünmüşse de
giriş çıkış işlemleriyle ilgili standart kütüphanenin bize sunduğu tüm arayüzden, interfejden bahsediyorum.
Sınıf hiyerarşisi üstünde konuşmuştuk. Bugün artık bellik üstünde okuma yazma işlemlerinden ziyade
dosyalar üstünde okuma yazma işlemlerine deyincez yani file operations, dosya işlemleri.
Önce biraz uyarmak istiyorum. Ne konuda?
Arkadaşlar şimdi bugün anlatacağım konuların bir kısmının iyi anlaşılması için
sizin zaten daha önceden dosyalarla ilgili bazı işlemleri yapmış olmanız, böyle kodlarla ilgilenmiş olmanız gerekiyor.
Yani örneğin C kursuna katılmış arkadaşlar.
Orada C'nin standart kütüphanesinde dosya işlemleriyle ilgili fonksiyonları görmüştük.
Bir hayli kod yazdık orada ve bazı temel konuları da orada anlatmıştım.
Mümkün olduğu kadar uzamaması için onlara değinmeyeceğim.
Yani onların bilindiğini varsayacağım.
Arkadaşlar nereden başlayalım?
Şuradan başlayalım.
Dosya işlemleri için bizim 3 tane temel sınıfımız var.
IfStream, OffStream ve FStream sınıfları.
Bu sınıfların hepsinin header file'ı standart kütüphanede FStream.
Yani dosyalarla ilgili bir işlem yapacaksak
FStream başlık dosyasını dahil etmemiz gerekiyor.
Niye gelmedi?
Evet, FStream başlık dosyasını dahil etmemiz gerekiyor.
Tabi bu başlık dosyası, bu header file'da kendi içinde başka başlık dosyalarını inklud ediyor.
Arkadaşlar önce şunu konuşmamız gerekiyor.
Yani ben standart kütüphanenin dosya işlemleriyle ilgili interfezini anlatacağım ama
nedir?
Dosyalarla ilgili programcının tipik yaptığı işlemler nelerdir?
Önce onları bir hatırlayalım.
SİDEK gibi detaylı anlatmayacağım ama en azından işlem gruplarını, kategorilerini bilmemiz gerekiyor.
Arkadaşlar öncelikle dosyanın açılması, dosyanın kapatılması.
Yani o dosya üstünde işlemleri yapabilmek için dosyayı işletim sisteminin sistem fonksiyonları
aslında arka planda gerekli hazırlık işlemlerini yapıyor, açıyor.
Ama bunun standart kütüphanede de bir şekilde karşılığı olmalı.
Örneğin SİDE dosyayı nasıl açıyoruz?
STUDIO başlık dosyasındaki FOPEN fonksiyonuna çağrı yaparak.
Yine dosyayı kapatmak için de FCLOSE isimli fonksiyonu çağırıyoruz.
Ama dosyayı açarken biz FOPEN fonksiyonuna dosya açış modu bilgisini gönderiyoruz.
Hatırlayınız, dosyanın açış modu ne demek?
İngilizcesiyle Open Mode.
Dosyanın açış modu iki tane önemli konu hakkında belirleyici.
Biri, dosya üstünde hangi işlemleri yapmaya hakkım var?
Hangi işlemleri yapmaya izin veriliyor?
Okuma, yazma gibi.
Diğeri, dosya varsa ne olacak?
Yani açmaya çalıştığım dosya varsa ne olacak?
Yoksa ne olacak?
Şimdi SİDEki dosya açış modlarında bildiğinizi varsayıyorum.
Mesela şöyle bir soru sorsam.
SİDE dosyayı yazma amaçla açarsam dosya yoksa ne olur?
Bir dosyayı yazma modunda açtım arkadaşlar ve o isimli dosya yok.
Ne olur?
Yanıt, dosya oluşturulur.
Bravo.
Oluşturulur, yenisi açılır.
Yani Rasul çoğu anlamda söylüyor.
İngilizce'de orada kullanılan fiil truncate edilir.
Yani örneğin açmaya, yazma amaçla açmaya çalıştığım dosya Rasul.txt dosyasıysa ben yazma amaçla açtığım zaman dosyanın eski içeriği gidecek.
Buna İngilizce'de dosyanın truncate edilmesi deniyor.
Peki başka bir soru.
Dosyayı append modunda açtığım zaman dosya yoksa arkadaşlar oluşturulur mu?
Cevap dosya yoksa oluşturulur.
Dosya varsa truncate edilir mi?
Cevap hayır.
Truncate edilmez değil mi?
Evet arkadaşlar işte bakınız bu artık daha fazla detaya girmiyorum.
Buradaki terimleri, kavramları biliyor olmanız gerekiyor.
Ondan sonra dosyadan yapılan okuma işlemleri ve dosyaya yapılan yazma işlemleri.
Okuma ve yazma yani arkadaşlar input, output, read, write işlemleri.
Ama read, write işlemleri, input, output işlemleri söz konusu olduğu zaman da formatlı ve formatsız olarak her ikisi de iki kategoriye ayrılıyor.
Formatted input, formatted input, formatted reading, unformatted.
Arkadaşlar arasındaki farkı biliyorsunuz.
Formatlı okuma ya da yazma demek karakter kodları üstünden okuma ve yazma demek.
Yani örneğin ben şöyle bir tam sayı değişkenim var int, i var.
Çok kısa bir hatırlatma yapalım.
Tam sayı değişkenimin değeri diyelim ki arkadaşlar 872.934.
Şimdi ben dosyaya bu karakterlerin kod numaralarını mı yazacağım yoksa bellekte diyelim ki size of int 4 ise 4 byte'ı olduğu gibi dosyaya transfer mi edeceğim?
İşte bakınız mesela C'de formatlı giriş çıkış fonksiyonları printf ve scanf grubu fonksiyonlar.
Örneğin dosyaya formatlı yazmak için fprintf dosyadan formatlı okumak için fscanf fonksiyonlarını çağırıyoruz.
Ama formatsız okuma yazma fonksiyonları fgeççe, fputçe, fread, fwrite gibi fonksiyonlar.
Yine dosya işlemlerinde bizi başka ne ilgilendiriyor?
Dosya işlemlerindeki başarısızlık.
Mesela bir okuma işlemi yapılamadığı zaman ne oluyor?
Ya da yazma işlemi yapılmamışsa bunu nasıl tespit ediyoruz?
Bütün bunlar bilmesi gerekiyor.
Ve başka bir de file pointer işlemleri.
Ben Türkçe'de, İngilizce'deki terim file pointer, Türkçe'de dosya konum göstericisi terimini kullanıyorum.
File pointer'ın ne olduğunu çok iyi bilmemiz gerekiyor.
Bir hatırlayalım mı?
C'ye yönelik olarak hatırlayalım.
Arkadaşlar dosyadan okuma yapan fonksiyonlar çağıran koddan dosyanın kaçıncı byte'ından başlayarak okuma yapayım sorusunun cevabını istemiyorlar.
Dosyaya yazma işlemi yapan fonksiyonlar yine çağıran koddan dosyanın kaçıncı byte'ından itibaren dosyaya yazayım sorusunun cevabını istemiyorlar.
İşte o kaçıncı byte anlamında daha çok kullanılan terim offset.
Peki neden?
Çünkü arka planda tutulan bir tam sayı değişken var.
Ona file pointer deniyor.
File pointer'ın değeri örneğin okunma işlemi yapılmadan önce 500 ise okuma fonksiyonu 500 indeksli byte'dan başlayarak okuyacak.
Aynı durum yazma işlemleri içinde geçerli.
Yazma yapan fonksiyon da file pointer'ın değeri olan indeksten başlayarak yazacak.
Okuyan fonksiyonlar dosyadan okuma işlemi yapan fonksiyonlar okudukları byte sayısı kadar yine yazma işlemi yapan fonksiyonlar yazdıkları byte sayısı kadar file pointer'ı arttıracaklar.
Böylece örneğin ben bir dosyadan döngüsel bir yapıda sürekli okuma işlemi yaparsam her okuduğum byte yeni bir byte olacak ki yazma işlemi için de aynı şekilde.
Arkadaşlar bu durumda böyle bir okuma yazmaya, dosyaya bu şekilde erişime popüler olarak sequential access deniyor.
Yiğitince, hocam tam ayrıntısını hatırlamıyorum ama C dersinde gördüğümüz Windows'a özel durum burada da geçerli mi?
Tabii ki.
O işletim sistemleri arasındaki bir fark.
Bravo onu hatırlamanız da çok güzel değil.
Kesinlikle burada da geçerli.
Ben ne olduğunu hatırlatayım mı Yiğit?
Tam hatırlamıyorum dediniz ya.
Hatırlatayım mı?
Diğer arkadaşlarım da belki daha önce duymamış olabilirler.
Arkadaşlar Yiğit Bey'in o C'den hatırladığı şu.
Yiğit benim C kursuma da katılmıştı.
Onun hatırladığı şu.
Şimdi dosyayı text modunda açmakla binary modda açmak arasındaki fark.
Unix kökenli sistemlerde kodun okunması açısından farkı göz önüne almazsanız aslında text moduyla binary modda arasında bir fark yok işlemlerin yapılması açısından.
Fakat Windows işletim sisteminde dosyayı text modunda açmakla binary modda açmak arasında hayati fark var.
Nedir?
İki tane önemli fark var.
Bir, dosyayı text modunda açarsanız newline karakterini dosyaya yazdığınızda tek bir byte olarak değil de iki byte olarak yazıyor.
13.10 çifti ASCII'deki yine dosyayı text modunda açıp dosyadan okuma yaparsanız ve ardışık 2 byte 13.10 ise onu newline olarak okuyor.
Yani okuma ve yazma işlemlerinde text modunda newline bir byte ile değil iki byte ile temsil ediliyor.
Tarihsel nedenlerden dolayı.
Yiğit hatırladınız mı?
Ama dosyayı binary modda açtığınızda böyle bir şey yok.
Yani örneğin newline'ı dosyaya yazdığınızda 10 tam sayı değerini ASCII kodlaması için bir byte olarak yazıyor.
Okurken de 13.10'u ayrı ayrı okuyor.
İkinci istisna, bir istisna daha var Alihan.
Onu da bakalım hatırlayan olacak mı?
C kursuna katılan Yiğit dışında kimse kaldı mı burada bilmiyorum ama.
Peki ben hatırlatayım onu da.
26'ın oğlu karakter.
Eskişehir'in plakasından aklınızda kalsın.
Eskişehir'in plakası 26 ya.
Arkadaşlar 26'ın oğlu karakter Ctrl-Z karakteri.
Yine tarihsel nedenlerden dolayı dosyayı text modunda açtığınızda
eğer okunan byte'ın tam sayı değeri 26 ise bunu dosya sonu kabul ediyor.
Ve örneğin fkc fonksiyonu size eof değerini döndürüyor.
Ama dosyayı binary modda açtığınızda 26'yı 26 olarak okuyorsunuz.
Bu da şu demek.
Yani Unix kökenli sistemlerde fark yok ama Windows'da dosyayı text modunda binary modda açmanız gerekirken text modunda açarsanız
tamamen işlem yanlış yapılacak.
Ki bu hata bazı kitaplarda da var.
Mesela kitapta yazılan kodlar bazı kitaplarda isim vermeyeyim bunu hiç göz önüne almamış.
Şimdi biz o zaman nereye geldik?
File pointer'ın ne olduğunu anlatıyordum.
Hatırlayın bakalım kim söyleyecek?
C'nin standart kütüphanesinde file pointer'ı get eden vs.t'den fonksiyonlar nelerdi?
Cevap fseg, ftel, rewind, fsetpos, fgetpos.
O zaman bunların da Iostream kütüphanesinde bir şekilde karşılığı olmalı.
Yalnız yine her konuda olduğu gibi bu konuda da biraz uyarmalıyım.
Arkadaşlar konu çok geniş.
Şimdi C++'ı öğrenmenin de biraz zor tarafı daha önce de konuşmuştuk bu.
Şimdi belirli ayrıntı seviyesine ineceğim ama ondan daha fazla ayrıntıya girersem
o zaman da geriye zaten kalmış 10-15 ders, kaç ders kalmış bir bakalım.
Derslerin, kalan derslerin hepsi 56-67 daha, 11 dersimiz kalmış.
Arkadaşlar geriye kalan derslerin hepsinin dosyalarla ilgili olması gerekiyor.
O da mümkün değil.
Mümkünse bugün tek parça baştan sona dosya işlemlerini anlatacağım.
Ama eksik kalan kısım olursa artık onu bir şekilde tamamlayacağız.
Ama tabii majör konuların hepsi ortalama bir programcının C++'ın standart kütüphanesini kullanarak
dosya işlemleri yapmasında herhangi bir şekilde bir engel olmayacak.
Efendim, başlık dosyamız AppStream dedik.
Arkadaşlar burada tahmin edebildiğiniz gibi yine Object Oriented bir ya da Object Based bir yaklaşım, approach var.
Yani bunlar stream değil mi?
Dosyalar da bir stream ve dosyaları kullanırken biz sınıf nesneleriyle temsil ederek kullanıyoruz.
Yani bir stream bir sınıf nesnesiyle temsil ediliyor.
İşte burada sınıf hiyerarşisinde belki hatırlayacaksınız en tepedeki sınıf iOS Base'di.
Ondan Basic iOS sınıfı kalıtım yoluyla elde ediliyordu.
Basic iOS sınıfından Virtual Inheritance'da Basic Iostream ve Basic Oostream sınıfları kalıtım yoluyla elde ediliyordu.
Ve ondan sonra hiyerarşide artık örneğin Basic arkadaşlar Iostream ve Basic Oostream'den çoklu kalıtımla Basic Iostream sınıfı elde ediliyordu.
Şimdi nasıl string sınıfları yani Iostream, Oostream, Oostream, String Stream nasıl bunlar arkadaşlar Iostream, Oostream ve Oostream sınıflarından kalıtım yoluyla elde ediliyorsa dosya sınıfları da öyle.
Bu da ne demek?
Üç tane sınıfımız var.
Biri IfStream.
Eğer bir dosyayı okuma modunda kullanacaksam yani dosyadan sağ okuma işlemi yapacaksam IfStream sınıfını kullanacağım.
Dosya üstünde sadece yazma işlemi yapacaksam OffStream sınıfını kullanacağım.
Arkadaşlar yalnız ben IfStream, OffStream diyorum ilk derste bunları anlattığım için tekrar etmiyorum.
Bunlar aslında hepsi türeş isimleri yani type alias.
Yani örneğin Basic Iostream diye bir sınıf şablonu var.
Onun şart, şart resim, şart açılımı specialization ile verilen eş isim.
Bütün bu giriş çıkış sınıfları en tepedeki taban sınıfı hariç o jenerik bir sınıf değildi.
Ondan sonraki bütün sınıflar jenerik yedi.
Ve IfStream.
Şimdi burada aslında enteresan bir şey var.
IfStream sınıfı türünden bir nesneyi kullanarak bir dosyadan okuma işlemi yapabilir miyim?
Evet, efendim IfStream sınıfı türünden bir nesneyi kullanarak dosyaya yazma işlemi yapabilir miyim?
Cevap hayır, doğrudan hayır.
Dolaylı olarak aslında o da mümkün.
Aynı şey OffStream için de yazma işlemi yapmama izin verecek.
İnterfeyz okuma yapmama izin vermeyecek.
Yani tahmin ettiğiniz gibi IfStream sınıfında okuma interfeysi var.
Yani örneğin dosyadan okuma işlemi yapan fonksiyonlar IfStream'in dolayısıyla üye fonksiyonları.
Tabi bunların önemli kısmı taban sınıflardan geliyor değil mi?
Aynı şekilde OffStream'de de, OffStream'de olduğu gibi yazma interfeysi var.
İşte biz daha önce de birkaç örnekte gördük.
Nasıl Cout, Operator, Left Shift'te formatlı yazıyor isek,
OffStream sınıfından kalıtım yoluyla elde edilen OffStream'de de,
yine OffStream sınıfının bu fonksiyonunu kullanabiliyoruz.
OffStream sınıfı ise, bir tane tabi.
OffStream sınıfı ise, hem okuma hem yazma interfeysine sahip.
Arkadaşlar çok özel bir durum yoksa,
okuma işlemleri için IfStream sınıfını,
yazma işlemleri için OffStream sınıfını,
ama aynı dosya üstünden,
hem okuma hem de yazma işlemi yapacaksanız aynı dosyaya,
o zaman OffStream sınıfını kullanacaksınız.
Aslında teknik olarak tahmin ediyorsunuz,
örneğin ben OffStream sınıfını kullanarak,
sadece okuma yapabilir miyim?
Evet, ama iyi bir teknik kabul edilmez.
Okuyanı yanıltırsınız ve hata yapma riski olur.
Diyelim ki dosyaya yazma işlemi yapmanız gerekmiyor,
ama OffStream yazma işlemine de izin veriyor.
Dolayısıyla yanlışlıkla bir yazma işlemi yaptığınızda,
onu gözden kaçırabilirsiniz.
Buraya kadar anlaşıldı mı bu sınıflar?
Evet, şimdi devam ediyoruz.
Arkadaşlar, burada ilk ve önemli ve en karışık konu olan bence dosya işlemlerinde,
dosyayı açmakla başlayalım.
Şimdi bakın, bir dosyayı açmak aslında işletim sistemi düzeyinde,
o dosyayla ilgili işlemleri yapmak için gerekli hazırlıkların tamamlanması demek.
Arkadaşlar, aslında dosya işlemlerinin hepsi işletim sisteminin kontrolünde.
Yani ister C olsun, ister C++ olsun, ister Java olsun,
sonuçta işletim sisteminin fonksiyonlarını ne yapıyor?
Sarmalıyor.
Bize ortak bir interface sağlıyor.
Öyle değil mi?
Dolayısıyla dosyayı açmak demek,
dosya üstünde artık ne yapacaksam, neye izin veriliyorsa,
bu işlemleri yapmak için gerekli zemini hazırlamak demek.
Şimdi burada programcının kafasını,
özellikle ilk defa dosya işlemleriyle ilgili çalışan programcının,
kafasını karıştıran bir durum var.
Nedir kafasını karıştıran durum?
Arkadaşlar, bunlar sınıf değil mi?
Örneğin ben dosya üstünde okuma işlemi yapmak için,
efendim, stut, ipstream türünden bir nesne oluşturacağım değil mi?
Evet.
Ama bakın şimdi,
bu stream nesneleri, file stream nesneleri,
A, bir dosyayla ilişkilendirilmiş olabilir.
B, henüz bir dosyayla ilişkilendirilmemiş olabilir.
Şimdi dosyanın açılması, kapanmasıyla dosyayla ilişkilendirme birbiriyle tamamen aynı şey değil.
Mesela, ben sınıfların default konstraktörüne çağrı yaparak sınıf nesnesi oluşturursam,
bu örneğe bakınız ekrandaki,
ipstream nesnesi hayatta ama ona bir dosya,
hani İngilizcesi de attach edilmemiş,
hiçbir dosyanın kontrolünü üstlenmiş durumda değil.
Yani bir stream nesnesinin hayatta olması,
onun kontrolünde olan açılmış bir dosyanın varlığına işaret etmiyor.
Ama işaretle edebilir, etme edebilir.
Mesela default konstrakt edilmiş bir stream nesnesine bağlı bir dosya yok.
Arkadaşlar, peki dosyayı açmak için ne yapacağız?
Dosyayı açmanın iki tane yolu var.
Biri doğrudan konstraktöre gereken argüman ya da argümanları geçmek.
Yani böylece benim ifstream, offstream, fstream nesnesi nesnelerimden biri konstrakt olduğunda,
konstraktörün herhangi bir şekilde tam bir exception vs. göndermeden ya da terminate etmeden program çalışmasıyla dosya açılmış oluyor.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet arkadaşlar, ikincisi daha sonra dosyayı sınıfın open fonksiyonuyla açmak.
Yani şimdilik detaylara bakmayın.
Örneğin böyle nesnem var zaten.
Sonra gidiyorum sınıfın open isimli fonksiyonuna çağır yaparak dosyayı açıyorum.
Arkadaşlar, dosyanın kapatılması zaten burada her zamanki gibi meşhur neyle gerçekleşiyor?
Arkadaşlar, rayi idiomuyla.
Yani konstraktör dosyayı açıyor ama destraktör kaynak sızıntısı olmaması için dosyayı kapatıyor.
Yani bir ifstream, offstream ya da fstream nesnesinin hayatı bittiğinde halen ona bağlı olarak kapanmamış,
close edilmemiş bir dosya varsa destraktör o dosyayı kapatacak.
Ama siz nesne destroy olmadan mesela o nesneyi tekrar başka bir dosya için kullanacaksınız ama dosyayı kapatıp yeni dosya açmak istiyorsunuz.
O zaman da sınıfın close fonksiyonunu çağırıyorsunuz.
Yani open fonksiyonuyla dosyayı açabiliyor, close fonksiyonuyla dosyayı kapatabiliyorsunuz.
Ama dosyanın açılmasını open fonksiyonuna çağrı yapmadan konstraktör yoluyla yapabiliyor.
Dosyanın kapanmasını da destraktörün çağrılmasına bırakabiliyorsunuz.
Buraya kadar her şey tamam mı?
Evet.
Şimdi gelelim bir parmaşık kısmına.
Arkadaşlar bakın dosya açış modu aslında doğrudan neyle ilgili diye sınıf nesnesinin kendisiyle ilgili değil.
Mesela şöyle bir şey yapabilir miyim?
Efendim bir tane ifstream nesnesiyle bir dosyayı açtım yazma modunda.
Sonra dosyayı kapattım.
Sonra tekrar bir dosya açtım.
Aynı sınıf nesnesini kullanıyorum ama bu sefer o sınıf nesnesini dosyadan okuma yapmak için dosyayı okuma modunda açarak kullanmak istiyorum.
Bu mümkün.
Şimdi gelelim dedik karmaşık kısmına biraz bizi yoracak kısmına ben şöyle bir tablo oluşturdum arkadaşlar.
Şimdi bakınız bu tabloyu anlamamız için ne olmamız gerekiyor ve aslında bu tabloyu da bir şekilde yanınızda bulundurmanızda dosya işlemleri yaparken fayda var.
Arkadaşlar gerek sınıfın konstruktörü birinci parametre olarak açılacak dosyanın ismini istiyor.
Bunun iki tane overload string olarak, still string olarak ya da g string olarak verebiliyorsunuz dosya ismini.
İkinci parametre ise dosyanın açış modunu temsil ediyor.
Ama dosyanın açış modu nasıl temsil ediliyor?
Buraya şimdi dikkat.
Arkadaşlar şimdiye kadar bu IO stream kütüphanesiyle ilgili belirli türleri gördük.
Bunlar tipik olarak bitmez ki de uygun türlerdi.
Örneğin fmt flex türü, örneğin IO state türü.
Burada da en tepedeki taban sınıfın open mode isimli bir türü var.
Hangi türün eş ismi olduğu derleyiciye bırakılmış.
Yine standardın tek koştuğu şart bitwise operationlara, bitsel operasyonlara uygun olması.
Yani Necati şöyle mi?
Stud, IOS Base'in arkadaşlar open mode türü.
Kesinlikle.
Tabi daha önceki dersleri hatırlayalım.
Böyle yazmakla taban sınıf olduğu için IOS Base, Basic IOS'un arkadaşlar şar açılımı onun süreç ismi de IOS'tu.
Şöyle de yazabilirsiniz değil mi?
Burası tamam mı?
Evet.
Yine tahmin edebildiğiniz gibi bu open mode türünden sabitler var.
Arkadaşlar mesela benim derleyicimde IOS Base'in open mode'u doğrudan int türünün eş ismi.
Yani ben örneğin bu türden bir değişken tanımlasam benim derleyicim için int türden bir değişken tanımlamış olacağım.
Arkadaşlar bu türden değişken, bu türden sabitler var.
Constex Bera sabitler var.
Onlar neler?
IOS'un in'i, IOS'un out'u, IOS'un app'si arkadaşlar, IOS'un at end'i, at e diye yazılıyor, IOS'un trunk'ı ve IOS'un ne kaldı?
Şimdi siz dosyayı açarken arkadaşlar, Constructor'a bu maskelerden birini ya da birden fazlasını bitsel veya operatörüyle kombine ederek fonksiyona gönderiyorsunuz.
Böylece dosyanın açış modunu belirliyorsunuz.
Bunların ne anlama geldiğini anlatacağım.
Zaten karmaşık yer burası.
Buraya kadar anladık mı?
Bunlar IOS Base'in open mode türünden sabitler.
C++ 23 standartıyla C++ 23'e girmeyelim ama bir de şöyle bir bitmez daha eklendi.
No Replace.
Arkadaşlar şimdi kısaca şöyle, biraz karmaşık ama in okumayı temsil ediyor.
Yani bir dosyayı açarken okuma modunu eklersem dosyadan okuma yapmak istediğim anlamına geliyor.
Ama buraya dikkat.
Mesela gidip de siz off stream sınıfı türünden bir nesneyi kullanarak açış modunda in flag'ini verirseniz dosyadan okuma işlemi yapabileceğiniz anlamına gelmiyor.
Çünkü onda zaten öyle bir interfej yok.
Out yazmayı temsil ediyor.
App arkadaşlar tahmin ediyorsunuz.
Append'i temsil ediyor.
Arkadaşlar kim biliyor?
Dosyanın append modda açılması ne demek?
Dosyanın append modda açılması dosyaya yazma işlemi yapabileceksiniz demek.
Ve her yazma işleminden önce file pointer dosyanın sonuna çekilecek.
Yani isteseniz de istemeseniz de siz yazdığınız zaman file pointer dosyanın sonuna çekildiği için dosyaya sadece ekleme yapabilirsiniz.
Yani dosyada örneğin yazma modunda açıksa app modu yoksa o zaman ne yapabilirsiniz?
Dosyadaki byte'ları değiştirebilirsiniz.
Ama salt append modunda açılırsa var olan byte'ı değiştirme şansınız yok.
Sadece arkadaşlar sonuna ekleme yapabilirsiniz.
Yine c'de olduğu gibi default açış modu text modu eğer dosyayı burası çok çok önemli işte Yiğit Bey'in sorduğu soru bununla ilgili dosyayı binary modda açmak istiyorsanız binary flagini açış moduna eklemek zorundasınız.
Yani onu eklemezseniz o zaman text modunda açılmış olacak.
Text modu için ayrı bir flag yok.
Yani ilave bir flag kullanmadığınız sürece text modu ama binary'yi kullanırsanız binary modda.
Şimdi bu açıklamalardan sonra şu benim de stack overflow'dan bir arkadaşım yapmış gayet güzel yapmış.
Ben böyle şöyle diyormuşum ben yapsam ancak bu kadar yapabilirdim.
Gerçekten çok güzel.
Bakın burada önce şunu bilmemiz gerekiyor.
Burayı çok dikkatli izleyelim.
Arkadaşlar siz ifstream sınıfı türünden bir nesne oluşturursanız izleyin.
Örneğin ifstream şöyle şimdilik namespace bildirimini yapalım.
Örneğin ifstream ifs birinci parametresine necati.txt'ye geçtim.
Arkadaşlar ikinci parametreye açış modunu geçeceğim ya.
Açış modunu geçmezsem zaten in ifstream için default geliyor.
Yani ifstream sınıfını kullanıp da açış moduna iOS'un inini eklememe ihtimali yok.
O her zaman var.
Yazsanız da var, yazmasanız da var.
Aynı şekilde upstream nesnesini kullandığınızda örneğin konstruktor'ın ikinci parametresine bir argüman geçmeseniz dahi
burada da ne modu var?
Hangi flag default geliyor?
Alt flag'i default geliyor.
Eğer ifstream değil, upstream değil, upstream'i kullanıyorsanız
ikinci parametreye, konstruktor'ın ikinci parametresine
yine bir flag geçmeseniz, open mode geçmeseniz dahi
bu seferde tahmin edin ne hazır geliyor?
Hem in hem out hazır geliyor.
Yani ifstream'de in'i doğrudan edinmiş oluyorsunuz.
Offstream'de out'u doğrudan edinmiş oluyorsunuz.
Fstream'de de hem in'i hem out'u edinmiş oluyorsunuz.
Bakın bu ne demek?
Mesela soru, bu kodun böyle olmasıyla
izleyin, bunu yorum satırına alalım.
Bu kodun böyle olmasıyla şöyle olması arasında bir fark var mı?
iOS'un in'i.
Cevap hayır.
Burayı anladık mı?
Yine aynı şekilde örneğin arkadaşlar
offstream
ops
derya.px'e
böyle yazmakla
ikinci parametreye
gidip de yazarsanız bir sakıncası yok şüphesiz.
Arkadaşlar ne yazmanız arasında bir fark yok?
iOS'un
out'u yazmanız arasında
bir fark yok.
Offstream içinde yazma şekli default geliyor mu?
Evet.
Zaten text
her zaman default
ama binary olması için
binary flag'in mutlaka eklenmesi lazım.
Oraya gelecektim ama madem Deniz sordu.
Yani açış moduna
şunu ilave etmediğiniz sürece
açış modu
hiçbir zaman binary mod
olamaz.
Anlaşıldı mı?
son olarak
fstream için
örneğin
construct'ları
böyle
çağırmakla
ikinci
open mod
parametresini isteyen
parametre değişkenini
takdirdim.
Tamam.
Bunu geçmek
arasında bir fark yok.
Anlaştık mı?
ifstream için in
offstream için out
hazır geliyor.
Şimdi bir şeye de dikkat.
Bu açış moduyla ilgili
söylediklerim
hem
constructor'ın
ikinci parametresi için
gerekli
arkadaşlar
hem de
open fonksiyonu için
takip edebildik mi?
Şimdi
Alihan Bozkır diyor ki
ikinci parametre
default 3 diyor.
Arkadaşlar
o sizin yardımcı
programınızın
verdiği destek.
Onun
3 olması
şu olması
yani
şimdi 3 olması
aslında
şuradan
bir bir
bir iki
gelmesi demek.
Örneğin
ama bu
standart değil ki.
Anladınız değil mi?
bu maskelerin
değerinin ne olduğu
tamamen
Alihan
derleyiciye bağlı.
Arkadaşlar
mesela bakın
aynı şey
açış tarafında da öyle.
Mesela şöyle
yazabilir miyim?
İzleyin.
Offstream
OPS
şimdi
Open
Bu şekilde
dosyayı açarsam
arkadaşlar
bu şekilde
dosyayı açarsam
yine
out
hazır geliyor.
mu?
Evet.
Mesela ben
out'un
yanı sıra
binary eklemek
istersem
şöyle de
yazabilirim.
iOS binary
çünkü
out
zaten
hazır geliyor.
Ya da
out'u
açıkça da
gösterebilirim.
Anlaştık mı?
Open
fonksiyonu
içinde böyle
constructor içinde
böyle.
Şimdi
binary'nin
okuma
yapabilir miyim?
Yazma
arkadaşlar bu arada
benim dilim alıştı ama
daha iyi bir seçenek de
bulamıyorum.
Okuma yapmak
Türkçe'de
bana çok düzgün
gelmiyor.
Yani bu anlamda.
Aslında
doğrusu
dosyadan
okumak.
Yani dosyadan
okuma yapabilirim
güzel bir Türkçe
değil.
Dosyadan
okuyabilirim.
Okuma yapmak
bunlar kötü.
mesela
trafik polisleri
böyle şeyle
hoparlörle
diyor ya
bekleme yapma
bekleme yapma.
Bekleme yapmak
ne demek?
Beklemek
bekleme yapmak
diye bir şey
aslında yok.
Neyse efendim
yani ben
böyle söylersem
kusuruma bakmayın.
Yiğit İnce'nin sorusu
hocam
kaçırmış
olabilirim.
Resul
diyor ki
bizde de yok
hocam
okuma
etmek oluyor
evet
Azeri Türkçesi'nde.
Yiğit İnce
hocam
kaçırmış
olabilirim.
Offstream'e
IOS in
geçersem
ne olur?
Offstream'e
IOS in
geçerseniz
bir sentaks
hatası
olmaz.
Ama
bu
okuma
yapabileceğiniz
anlamına
gelmiyor.
Okuyabileceğiniz
anlamına
gelmiyor.
Anlaşıldı
değil mi?
Çünkü
Offstream'de
zaten
okuma
işlemleri
için
fonksiyonlar
yok.
Anlaşıldı
mı?
Yiğit
evet
peki
şimdi gelelim
şu tablonun
yorumuna
işte
kafa karıştıran
yer burası.
Arkadaşlar
bu arada
hemen
bir şey daha
söyleyeyim
oraya gelmeden
binary'ni
dosya varsa
ne olacak
yoksa
bununla
ilgisi yok.
Binary
flag'i
dosyanın
binary modda
açıldığı
anlamına
geliyor.
Anlaşıldı
değil mi?
Yani
okuma yapabilir
miyim?
Yazma yapabilir
Yine
söyledim
her söylediğimde
kafama
internet
vuracağım.
dosyadan
okuyabilir miyim?
Dosyaya
yazabilir miyim?
Bunun
binary flag'le
alakası yok.
Dosya varsa
ne olacak?
Dosya yoksa
Bunun da yine
binary flag'iyle
alakası yok.
Arkadaşlar
C'de
olmayan
burada
ilginç bir flag var.
Yani
C'nin
standart
kütüphanesinde
yok.
Sonra
bir dosyayı
açtığımda
C'de
fopen
fonksiyonuyla
ister dosyayı
okuma
modunda
açayım
ister dosyayı
yazma
modunda
açayım.
Dosya konum
göstericisi
file pointer
dosya açıldığında
hangi değerde
olur?
File pointer'ın
değeri nedir
dosya açıldığında?
Cevap
tabii ki
sıfır
sıfırdır.
Tabii ki
offset
işte offset'in
değeri nedir?
Deniz onu
soruyorum
sıfır.
yani
örneğin
okuma
amaçlı
dosyayı
açarsanız
ilk okuma
işleminde
dosyanın
başından
başlayarak
okumuş
olursunuz
değil mi?
Peki
diyelim ki
siz dosyayı
açar
açmaz
dosya
konum
göstericisini
dosyanın
sonuna
alacaksınız.
Bu durumda
dosyayı
açıp
örneğin
fsik
fonksiyonuyla
hatırlayın
arkadaşlar
fsik
şöyle
değil mi?
fsik
f
sıfır
ancak
böyle bir
çağrı
yaparsanız
dosya
konum
göstericisini
dosyanın
sonuna
almış
olursunuz.
F burada
file handle.
Fakat
einström
kütüphanesinde
ilginç
bir flag
var
o da
ate
ateist
anlamında
değil
aslında
neden
uydurulmuş
at
and
uydurulmuş
at
and
ate bayrağını
koyarsanız
neyi
sağlıyor?
Dosya
açıldığında
dosya
konum
göstericisi
yani
file
pointer
sıfır
değerinde
değil de
dosyanın
sonunda
oluyor.
dosyayı önce
açıp
file pointer'ı
sona almak
istiyorsanız
bunu yapmak
yerine
dosyayı açarken
açış modu
bilgisine
hangi flag'i
eklemeniz
yeterli?
et and
flag'ini
eklemeniz
yeterli.
Burayı anladık mı
Yiğit,
Deniz,
Alihan,
Kaan,
Mehmet Can
anladık umarım.
Peki
devam ediyorum.
Arkadaşlar
binary'nin ve
et and'in
işte
dosyaya
yazabilir miyim
okuyabilir miyim
dosya varsa ne olacak
yoksa ne olacak
bu soruların
cevabıyla alakası yok.
O yüzden
tabloda bunları
görmeyeceksiniz.
Şimdi
bakınız
çok dikkatli
izleyelim.
diyor ki
eğer
sen
out flag'ini
verirsen
ki
upstream'de
bu hazır geliyor
ne diyor
explanation
create a file
for writing
dosyayı
oluşturmuş
oluyorsunuz.
Buraya dikkat
arkadaşlar
ve dosya
truncate ediliyor
yani
trunk bayrağını
eğer
eklemeseniz
dahi
sadece
out ile
açıyorsanız
upstream
nesnesini
kullanarak
yine
dosyayı
truncate
ediyor.
Dolayısıyla
arkadaşlar
ister
offstream'de
mesela bu ne demek
fiilen şu demek
değil mi
offstream için
soru
ali.txt
dosyayı
oluşturacak mı
evet
dosyaya
yazma işlemi
yapabilirim
evet
ali.txt
varsa
o
sizlere ömür
ne demek
yani ölüyor
yani onu
sıfırlamış
oluyorum
doğru mu
doğru
yani onu
truncate
etmiş
oluyorum
işte bakın
şöyle yazmakla
izleyin
şöyle yazmak
aynı şey
hatta
şöyle yazmakla
aynı şey
ios
out
hazır geliyor
çünkü
anladık mı
tamam
şimdi tabloya
devam edelim
biraz üstünden
geçmeniz gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
dosyayı
bakınız
eğer
out
modunda
açıyorsanız
ve
app bayrağını
da flag'in
de veriyorsanız
artık
dosyaya
sadece
sona
ekleme
şeklinde
yazabilirsiniz
yani
app
bayrağı
eklendiği
anda
artık
yazma
işlemi
var olan
byte'ların
üstüne
yazarak
over
write
ederek
o kalıtımdaki
over write'dan
bahsetmiyorum
yapılamaz
ve
arkadaşlar
görüyorsunuz
append
bayrağını
eklediğiniz
zaman
her zaman
yeni dosya
oluşturuluyor
yoksa
eğer dosya
varsa
arkadaşlar
var olan
dosyayı
kullanıyorsunuz
anlaşıldı
değil mi
evet
işte
eğer
in bayrağı
varsa
ki
if stream'de
hazır geliyor
o zaman
dosyadan
okuma
işlemi
yapıyorsunuz
yapabiliyorsunuz
in ve
out varsa
ki bu
if stream için
geçerli
doğal olarak
arkadaşlar
dosya yoksa
dosya
açılamıyor
tıpkı
in'de
olduğu gibi
ama
dosya varsa
dosya açılıyor
in'de de böyle
arkadaşlar
trunk bayrağını da
koyarsanız
yani
hem in
hem out
hem de
trunk bayrağı
varsa
evet dosyadan
okuma da
yapabiliyorum
yazma da
okuyabiliyorum
yazı da
biliyorum
ve
arkadaşlar
hayır hayır
exception fırlatmıyor
şimdi
exception konusunda
en sonunda
değineceğim
ama madem
Oğuzhan Esin
arkadaşım
sordu
exception ile
ilgisini
anlatayım
bir parantez
açıp
çok kısa
arkadaşlar
şimdi
dosya işlemleri
varsayılan
şekilde
exception
göndermiyor
bunun
iki nedeni
var
birinci
nedeni
eğer
exception
gönderseydi
ben
exception
göndermemesini
istediğim
durumlarda
yapabilecek
bir şeyim
olmazdı
ama
default olarak
exception
göndermediği
zaman
benim
kendi
seçimimle
exception
gönderiyor
hale
state'e
getirme
olan
an var
Oğuzhan
anlaşıldı mı
yani defaultta
kesinlikle
hiçbir dosya
işlemi
exception
göndermiyor
ama
mesela ben
şunu yapabilir
miyim
hayır efendim
ben dosyadan
okuma
işlemi
yaptığımda
exception
okuma
başarısız
olduğunda
exception
throw edilsin
diyebilir miyim
bu bir soru
cevap
evet
ya da
şu koşulda
exception
throw edilsin
diyebilir miyim
cevap
evet
ya da
hangi koşulda
exception
throw edildiğini
edildiği
bilgisini
get edebilir miyim
cevap
evet
peki bunu
nasıl sağlıyorum
bakın bakın
son derece
basit
bu
stream
sınıflarının
avans sınıfından
gelen
exceptions
isimli
bir
fonksiyon
var
bakın
C'nin
arkadaşlar
evet
exceptions
bakın şimdi
bu
hem
get
fonksiyonu
hem
set
fonksiyonu
eğer
get
fonksiyonu
olarak
çağırırsanız
size bir
io state
döndürüyor
o
io state
hangi
flagler
set edildiğinde
exception
göndereceğini
anlatıyor
o zaman
tahmin edin
default durumda
exception
throw
etmediğine
göre
exceptions
fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değeri bu
durumda
arkadaşlar
good bit
olacak
yani o da
sıfır
olması
demek
değil mi
ama
diyelim ki
a of bit
set edildiğinde
exception
gönderiyorsa
geri dönüş
değeri olan
io state
a of bit
değerinde
olacak
burayı
anladık mı
şimdi
Oğuzhan
hangi
koşulda
exception
göndermesini
istiyorsanız
exceptions
fonksiyonuna
bu bayraklardan
birini ya da
birden fazlasını
argüman olarak
göndereceksiniz
mesela şöyle
yaparsanız
ne anlama gelir
deneyin isterseniz
şöyle yazarsanız
bu ne anlama gelir
tahmin edin
siz artık
a of bit
set edildiğinde
exception
göndermesini
istiyorsunuz
eğer böyle
yazmak yerine
şöyle
yazarsanız
arkadaşlar
hangi koşulda
exception
göndermesini
istiyorsunuz
cevap
bad bit
set edildiğinde
bu konuyu
hatırlıyoruz
değil mi
condition state'i
hatırlıyoruz
değil mi
eğer örneğin
şöyle yazarsanız
arkadaşlar
bu ne demek
pale bit
set edildiğinde
exception
trovedilsin
demek
ya da
örneğin
şöyle yazsaydım
a of bit
arkadaşlar
bitsel veya
ios'un
efendim
bad biti
bu ne anlama
gelecekti
bu bitlerden
biri
set edilirse
bu clicklerden
biri
set edilirse
exception
trove edecek
arkadaşlar
bakın zaten
bunu da gösterebilirim
olsan
vaktinizi alıyorum
ama madem
olsan sordu
bu konuyu
arayalım
zaten sadece
dosya işlemleriyle
ilgili değil ki
bütün okuma
yazma işlemleriyle
ilgili
bakınız
int x
c out
bir tam sayıya
girin
c in
x
sadece beni izleyin
şimdi diyelim ki
bir hatalı giriş yapayım
vermiyorum
bir tam sayı girin
arkadaşlar
bilal
bilal olan
herhangi bir şekilde
exception
trovedli mi
aslında giriş başarısız
değil mi
yiğit olsan
giriş başarısız
ama exception
trovedli mi
ayıttı
ama şimdi
bakın
c'nin
exception'sı
ios'un
fail biti
bu ne demek
ios'un fail biti
bir okuma işleminde
set edilirse
yani bu flag set edilirse
exception
gönderecek
isterseniz deneyelim
bir tam sayı girin
murat
arkadaşlar
bakın
exception gönderildi
ve ben gönderilen
exception'i
yakaladım
mesela şuna
bakın
arkadaşlar
ios'un
eof biti
ali
exception gönderecek mi
göndermeyecek mi
bu bir soru
evet en az bir
arkadaşım cevap versin
tutan exception gönderecek mi
göndermeyecek mi
cevap
hayır göndermeyecek
çünkü
eof bit set edilmiyor ki
öyle değil mi
eof turumu yok ki
format uyumsuzluğu
olduğu için
anlaşıldı değil mi
burayı anladık mı
ben ne dedim
eof bit set edildiğinde
exception göndersin
dedim
bravo
eof tabu
sisteme bağlı ama
bakın
ctrl z
enter
standart input'un
buffer'ını
boş bıraktım
şimdi
eof bit set edildi
bu durumda
exception gönderildi
oğuzhan bey
exception gönderme
göndermeme durumunu
anladık mı
her şey neye bakıyor
bir tane fonksiyon var
exceptions fonksiyonu
hem
get fonksiyonu
hem set fonksiyonu
arkadaşlar
get set fonksiyonu
derken
neyi kastediyorum
bakın
şimdi diyelim ki
elimde bir stream nesnesi var
ama bu nesne
benim
benim değil
başka bir kodu
yani sahibi
ben değilim
e şimdi şunu
öğrenmek istiyorum
acaba bu exception
troll ediyor mu
etmiyor mu
o zaman şöyle yazabilirim
değil mi
bakın
auto
arkadaşlar
state
eşittir
c'nin
exceptions'ı
oradan da yazabilirdim
siz görün
tabi ki buradaki
state'in
türü
ios
state
türü
yani
havan sınıfın
auto
state
türü
şimdi bakın
if
state
bitsel ve
arkadaşlar
ios'un
eof biti
önce
eof bitin
set edilip edilmediğini
anlıyorum
değil mi
ve
o zaman şöyle
diyebilirim
eof bit
yani
tabi kodda karşılığı
ne olacaksa
set edilmişse
set edildiğinde
troll ediyor
yani şimdi
size neyi göstermek istedim
get fonksiyonunu
göstermek istedim
parametresi olan
get fonksiyonunu
göndermek istedim
evet bakın
eof bit set edildiğinde
troll ediyor
gördük mü
ama şöyle olsaydı
mesela
bakınız
bad bit
set edildiğinde
troll ediyor
o çıkmadı
ama
o state
olsaydım
gördüğünüz
değil mi
ios bit
eof bit
set edildiğinde
atıram ediyor
peki
arkadaşlar
şimdi çok
dikkatli
izliyorsunuz
az önceki
tablodan
şuraya biraz
daha gidelim
bakın
şunların
anlamını
söyledim
in
open for reading
out
open for writing
trunk
işte
truncate
ate
türkçe okuyorum
go to the end of the file
after opening
yani dosya konum gösterisini
dosyanın sonuna al
binary
binary mode
şimdi şuraya
geri dönecek olursak
sadece beni izleyin
buraya geri dönecek olursak
arkadaşlar
bazı
operasyonlarda
izleyin
mesela
failure to open
ya da error
yani dosya
açılamazsa
bir hata
durumu oluyor
değil mi
işte burada
dosyanın
açılamaması
durumunda
normalde
Kaan Can
C olsaydı
f open'ı
çağırdığımızda
dosyanın
açılıp
açılmadığını
nasıl test ediyorduk
arkadaşlar
dosyanın
açılıp
açılmadığını
test etmek için
bravo
geri dönüş
değerinin
null pointer
olup olmadığına
bakıyorduk
ama burada
dosya
açılamazsa
stream
fail
durumuna
geliyor
dolayısıyla
diyelim ki
benim
izleyin
arkadaşlar
okuma amaçlı
bir dosyayı
açacağım
bakınız
ifstream
ifs
arkadaşlar
ahmet
can
ya da şöyle
diyelim
yok
bu dosya
gerçekten bu
isimli bir
dosya yok
şimdi
dosyanın
açılıp
açılmadığını
nasıl
kontrol edeceğim
bunun
birden
fazla yolu var
arkadaşlar
son derece
basit
dosya
açılamazsa
stream
nesnesi
fail
state'e
geçiyor
o zaman
aslında
tek yapmam
gereken
fail
state'de
olup olmadığını
test etmek
arkadaşlar
bunun en
pratik yolu
benim sevdiğim
yolu
operatör
lojik değil
zaten o
fail'i çağırıyor
o zaman şöyle
if
değil
ifs
bakın
crr
bundan da bahsetmedik
ama
inşallah
ona da
vaktimiz kalır
crr
yani
hata
streamine
error streamine
yazıyorum
dosya
türkçe
yazıyorum
açılamadı
return 1
bakın
dolayısıyla
bu dosya
açılamadığı
için
görüyorsunuz
dosya
açılamadı
yani
kontrolü
böyle yapmak
da bu
bir
şöyle yapmak
arasında
bir fark
var mı
if
ifs
fail
cevap
hiç bir fark
yok
bakın yine
oraya
girecek
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
dolayısıyla
ister
operatör
değil
fonksiyonlu
ister
arkadaşlar
fail
fonksiyonlu
hatta şunu bile
yazabilirsiniz
ama ne gerek var
ifs
good durumunda
değil ise
ama şimdi bakın
lütfen çok dikkatli izleyin
kafa karıştıran bir yere
geleceğiz
open fonksiyonuyla
open ne yapıyor
dosyayı açıyor
yani bir stream
nesnesine bağlı
bir dosya yoksa
ama ben ona
bir dosyanın
kontrolünü vereceksem
open fonksiyonunu
çağırabilirim
close da dosyayı
kapatıyor
fakat
arkadaşlar
bir de
is open
isimli bir fonksiyon var
fonksiyonu
stream
nesnesinin
kontrolünde
bir dosya var mı
yok mu
onu kontrol ediyor
mesela
bakınız
herkes dikkatli
izliyor
çünkü bu çok
karıştırılıyor
programcı tarafından
see out
boğul alfa
bunun ne olduğunu
biliyorsunuz
izleyin
if stream
ifs
arkadaşlar
is open
ifs
nokta koymamışı
bunun için
tamamlamıyor
is open
poşul operatörü
true
döndürecek
false mu
cevap
ifs'e
bravo
false
açıklama yapmama bile gerek yok
peki
şimdi izleyin
ifs
open
aynı yerde
nutility
nokta
h
soru
bu dosya açılırsa
is open
true mu döndürecek
false mu
cevap
true
çünkü ona bağlı
artık bir dosya var
bakın
dosya açılmaz
dosya açma işlemi
başarısız
olsaydı
o zaman
true mu döndürecekti
false mu
yine false
döndürecekti
izleyin
arkadaşlar
dosyayı
muhammet yusuf
kapatıyorum
ifs
close
peki
demin dosya
açıktı
değil mi
şimdi
aynı statementı
tekrar çalıştırırsam
true mu
olacak
false mu
bakın
bravo
false
olsan
neden
benim
ifstream
nesnem
hayatta
ama
artık
onun
kontrolünde
bir dosya
yok
is open'ın
anlamını
kavradınız
değil mi
şimdi tekrar
bir dosya
açsam
tekrar
is open
true
döndürecek
ama sosyal
şöyle bir
durum var
izleyin
tekrar
ilk sorumuza
geri dönelim
hani
dosya
açıldı mı
açılmadı mı
nasıl
kontrol edeceğiz
sorusuna
e o zaman
bunu kontrol etmenin
bir yolu daha var
aslında
o da
is open
fonksiyonunu
çağırmak
bazıları da
böyle yazıyor
değil
ifs
is open
yani
false
değer döndürmüşse
normalde dosya
açılmışsa
true
değer döndürmesi
lazım
o zaman
yine
dosyanın
açılamadığını
anlıyorum
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
arkadaşlar
şimdi
eğer
diyelim ki
dosya
açılamazsa
hep aynı işi yapacaksanız
kod tekrarından
kaçınmak için
ben
ilerleyen dakikalarda
göstereceğim
bunu bir fonksiyona
bağlayabilirsiniz
bir fonksiyon
yazabilirsiniz
bu stream
nesnelerinin
kopyalanamadığını
ama
taşınabildiğini
hatırlayalım
yani bu sınıflar
kopyalamaya karşı
kapatılmış
ama taşımaya
karşı açık
bunun neden
önemli olduğunu
göreceğiz
Yiğit İnce'nin
sorusu
hocam
ben böyle
deyince
Ramazan'da
böyle sorular
soruyorlar ya
şeylere
dini
ne diyelim
ulema mı
denir
alimlere
hocam
kurban keseceğim
şöyle şöyle oldu
bu caiz midir
hocam
doğrudan
ismi belli bir
dosyanın açık
olup olmadığını
kontrol edebileceğimiz
bir yol var mı
arkadaşlar
onun
doğrudan
kontrolü yok
ama şunu yapabilirsin
F.O.P.N.
caiz midir
ne diyor Deniz
ama şunu
yapabilirsiniz
bir dosyanın
açılabilir
olup olmadığını
yani o isimli
bir dosya
olup olmadığını
ilgili
direktörü de
o isimli
bir dosya
olup olmadığını
açılıp
açılma
okunma
amaçlı
açmaya
çalışırsınız
açılmazsa
o dosyanın
yok olduğuna
hükmedebilirsiniz
ama bu bile
sağlam bir yol
değil
arkadaşlar
başka bir
modern
C++'a
eklenen
ama bu
kursun
kapsamında
olmayan
file system
kütüphanesi var
orada
buna yönelik
bir
interfej var
ama ona
maalesef
kursda
değinmeyeceğim
peki
ama bir şeyde
dikkat
arkadaşlar
şimdi dosya
açıldığı zaman
açılamamasının
nedeni sadece
dosyanın
olmayışı
değil
mesela dosyada
arka planda
bir bufferlama
sistemi var
daha önce
söylemiştik
demiştik ki
perde arkasındaki
gerçek kahraman
aslında buffer
sınıfı
türünden bir
nesne
şimdi o bufferda
arka planda
biz görmesek de
o bufferın
elde edilmesi için
yani buffer dediğim
bir bellek alanı
dynamic allocation
oluyor
dolayısıyla
orada da bir
başarısızlık
olursa
yine dosya
açılmayabilir
yani dosyanın
açılamamasının
farklı farklı
nedenleri olabilir
ama o nedenlerden
hiçbiri söz konusu
değilse
örneğin okuma
modunda olmayan
bir dosyayı
açma girişinde
bulunduğunda
arkadaşlar
ne olacak
efendim
dosya açma
işlemi
başarısız olacak
akım
fail durumuna
gelecek
şimdi önce
okuma
tarafı
yazma tarafı
bunları bir görelim
arkadaşlar
önce
formatlı
formatsız
okuma yazma
aslında bunu
ben size
hiç
anlatmayacağım
bile
neden
şimdi soru
neden daha önce
öğrendiklerimizin
önemli olduğuna
bakın
soru
ben
dosyaya
formatlı
yapacağım
peki nasıl
format state'i
ayarlayacağım
e bunları
zaten gördük
hatırlayın
yani şöyle
yazabilir miyim
örneğin
offstream
ops
bir dosya
oluşturayım
arkadaşlarımdan
birinin ismi
olsun
deniz
ak
nokta txt
belki olabilir
diye txt
izleyin
if
zaten
bunu da ben
snippet haline getirmiştim
yanlış hatırlamıyorsam
bakın
o
spek
alt nokta txt
kalsın
şimdi izleyin
ops
set f
yani
formatlama konusunda
öğrendiğimiz
her şeyi
dosya
file stream
nesneleriyle de
kullanabilir miyim
set f
un set f
manipülatörleri
o stream manipülatörlerini
if stream
sınıfı için
i stream
manipülatörlerini
kullanabilir miyim
evet
efendim
state'i kontrol etmek
için
state ile ilgili
öğrendiğimiz her şeyi
kullanabilir miyim
bravo
bir kısmı
ios
based
olduğu için
okuma işlemleri de
formatlı okuma
yazma işlemlerini
nasıl yapabiliyorum
o da
aslında
i stream'den
ve o stream'den
geliyor değil mi
dolayısıyla
bakınız
sonuçta
bunu daha önce de
yaptık
mesela şöyle dersem
ops
arkadaşlar
efendim
i
birer
boşluk
işte
ben burada
stu siyah alt nesnesini
kullansaydım
standart alt
buta yazacaktı
şimdi
defalarca da
bunun örneğini
yaptık
daha önce
biraz ezbere
gitmiştik
alt nokta
txt dosyasına
yazacak
bu algoritmalar
yazma algoritmaları
için de
geçerli
o stream iterator
sınıfını
kullanırken de
geçerli
değil mi
bakınız
alt nokta
txt
değil mi
evet
ya da
mesela
utility
başlık dosyasını
ekleyeyim
izleyin
ve
o fs
efendim
bak neydi bizim
i rent
bakın bakın şimdi
my rent
diyelim ki
sıfır
ya da şöyle olsun
formatlama zahmetinden
kurtarsın bizi
efendim
izleyin o fs
my rent
arada bir boşluk
arkadaşlar
efendim
random name
random
surname
ve
diyelim ki
100 tane
bakın normal
bunu
o stream olan
standart
output'a
yazmamla
dosya yazmam
arasında
göreceğiniz gibi
bir fark
yok
evet
bakınız
arkadaşlar
out nokta
txt
formatlama
da öyle
mesela şimdi
isimler
soy isimler
alt alta gelmedi
değil mi
ama
iomanip
başlık dosyasını
dahil etseydim
örneğin
ismi yazdırmadan
önce
set with
manipülatörünü
kullanarak
16 karakterlik
alana
yazmasını
sağlasaydım
yine aynı
şekilde
arkadaşlar
o fs
set f
ya da
artık hangisi
sola dayalı
yazmak için
left manipülatörünü
kullansaydım
hatta
bakınız
o fs
fil
bütün hepsini
formatlama
interfejini
bu şekilde
kullanabilir
şimdi
16 karakterlik
alana yazacak
şimdi bakın
alt nokta
txt
16 karakterlik
alana
sola dayalı
olarak yazdı
eğer şöyle
olsaydı
bu
left manipülatörünü
kullanmadan
yapalım
yani
formatlı
girişik işlemlerini
ben anlatmayacağım
bile
önemli bir
kısmını
belki
gereken
bir iki tane
daha önce
söylemediğim şey
varsa
ona değinirim
çünkü
formatlama
interfejisi
zaten
taban sınıftan
geliyor
set f
fonksiyonu
anset f
manipülatörler
kendi parametreli
manipülatörlerimi
kullanabilirim
daha önce
gördüğümüz üzere
değerli
arkadaşlar
evet
peki
yalnız bir şeye
dikkat edelim
şimdi
C'nin standart
kütüphanesiyle
arada
önemli bir
fark var
bu
bazen
işletim sistemi
buna izin veriyor
programcıyı da
yanıltıyor
arkadaşlar
streamde
bir
hata olduğu
zaman
mesela diyelim ki
eofbit set edildi
akım fail durumuna
düştü
düştüğü zaman
orada
artık o nesneyle
bir şey yapmanızın
garantisi yok
işte burada
daha önceden
öğrendiğimiz
clear fonksiyonu
hata bayraklarını
set ediyor
yani
akım fail durumuna
düştü
ama ben
yine bir
okuma işlemi
yapmayı
deneyeceğim
eğer
hata bayrağını
clear etmezseniz
yani örneğin
nasıl daha önce
C'nin
clear çağrısı
yapmıştık
hata bayrağını
clear etmezseniz
arkadaşlar
o zaman
yine okuma
başarı olmak
zorunda
değil
şimdi
en basit
okuma
yazma işlemlerinden
başlayalım
arkadaşlar
tek bir
karakter
okumak için
tek bir karakter
nasıl
C'de
F geçe
fonksiyonu
varsa
I-Stream
sınıfından
ne geliyor
değerli arkadaşlar
Get fonksiyonu
geliyor
bu sınıfın
üye fonksiyonu
üstelik iki tane
ayrı Get
overloadu var
Get
overloadlarından
bir tanesi
şöyle göstereyim
arkadaşlar
diyelim ki
ifs
bir
ifstream
nesnesi
Get
eğer
parametresiz
çağırırsanız
bu durumda
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
okunan
karakter
yani örneğin
std
ifstream
ifs
bir tane
dosya alalım
mesela burada var
utility.h
ve ben
formatsız olarak
dosyası
açılamadı
formatsız olarak
byte byte
okuma yapmak istiyorum
tek yapmam gereken
sınıfın
Get fonksiyonunu
çağırmak
gösterip
iki farklı şekilde
çağırabilirim
burası
biraz kafamızı
karıştırabilir
ama aslında
o kadar da değil
bakın bakın
birincisi
ifs'nin
parametresiz
Get fonksiyonunu
çağırırsınız
bu tabi ki
arkadaşlar
iStream
sınıfından geliyor
izleyin
fonksiyonun geri dönüş
değeri
int
yani
okunan
byte'ın
tam sayı değerini
döndürüyor
okuma başarısız
olduğunda
eof
döndürüyor
arkadaşlar
yani şöyle bir
döngü
oluşturabilirsiniz
izleyin
tıpkı
siyili olduğu
gibi
o gibi
line
oto
c
eşittir
ifs'nin
geti
arkadaşlar
ve
c
eşit olmadığı
sürece
buna
şöyle yapalım
isterseniz
c'deki
idiom gibi
yapalım
int c
eşittir
ifs'nin
geti
ya da
baştan
tanımlayabilirsiniz
yani yazmanın
envahı
şişli yolu var
sizde hepsini
bunların anlatıyorum
bakın
c eşittir
ifs'nin
geti
atama
operatörünün
ürettiği değer
nesneye atanan
değer olduğu için
hatırlıyoruz
değil mi
eşit değilse
arkadaşlar
eof
o zaman
okuma başarılı
ne zaman
eof döndürür
işte
o zaman
eof state'e
geçmiş demek
önce
rasulünün
sorusuna
bakalım
oradan peki
hem c'de
hem c++'da
aynı olan
fonksiyonları
c ile mi
c++'la mı
yazmamızı
tercih edersiniz
yani yalnızca
bu konu için
demiyorum
sd'li her zaman
kullanalım mı
arkadaşlar
bence
ortada
makul bir neden
olmadıkça
rasul
hep ben böyle
söylüyorum
ortada
size
çıkartacak
makul bir neden
olmadıkça
durup dururken
c++'da
c'nin
standart
kütüphanesinden
gelen fonksiyonları
kullanmayın
bazı durumlarda
birbiriyle
karıştırırsanız
belki bir derste
ona da
değinebilirim
bazı
senkronizasyon
problemleri de
olabilir
evet
c eşitir
ifs'nin
geti
bakın bakın
o stream
sınıfının da
yine formatsız
put fonksiyonu var
görüyor musunuz
arkadaşlar
izleyin
ifs'nin geti
eşit olmadığı
yanlış yazmışım
şurayı
arkadaşlar
ve
ifs'nin
geti
arkadaşlar
eşit olmadığı
sürece
eo
ip yazmışım
ya ben de
diyorum ki
nerede hata var
kimse de söylemiyor
necati valilerine
if yazdı
tamam şimdi
o
evet bakınız
gördüğünüz gibi
dosyanın
hepsini
byte byte okudu
arkadaşlar
yalnız bakın
bazı okuma işlemleri
için
skip
vs
white space
state'i
önem taşıyor
bazıları için
taşımıyor
şimdi izleyin
bakalım burada
önemli mi
ifs
no
skip
vs
tüç okuyorum
skip
white space
den geliyor
ifs
ders yazmışım
ben de
evet
ay olsun
arkadaşlar
ee
ne oldu
bir dakika
ifs
orada
bu tamam
manipülatörün
ismi
ayos
önce onu bir yazalım
o zaman ben de
işeşeceğim
ayos
skip
vs
tamam
ister şöyle yazın
setf'yi çağırın
ifs
ismi manipülatörü
kullanın
setf
ayos
skip
vs
ama bunun
listesinde
cp3
refhaz.com'dan
bakabilirsiniz
hangi operasyonlar
arkadaşlar
ondan etkileniyor
hangileri
etkilenmiyor
dikkat ederseniz
şimdi
skip vs
modunda
değil
ama
eğer okumayı
formatlı şekilde
yapsaydım
yani
operatör
write chip
fonksiyonuyla
yapsaydım
o zaman
skip
white space
manipülatörü
etkili olacaktı
yani bazı
okuma işlemlerinde
bu formatlı ya da
formats olduğuna
bağlı olarak
arkadaşlar
white space'i
geçip
geçmemesini
ayarlayabiliyorsunuz
neyse
buraya geri dönelim
get fonksiyonunun
ikinci
overload'u
daha kolay
arkadaşlar bakın
bazı
okuma yazma
fonksiyonları
örneğin formatlı
okuma
formatlı yazma
fonksiyonları
hatırlayın
geri dönüş
değeriyle
stream nesnesinin
kendisini
döndürüyor
dolayısıyla
lojik
bağlamda
kullandığınız zaman
eğer akım
fail durumundaysa
örneğin
döngüden çıkıyor
işte onun
çok tipik bir örneği
bir de
her referans
parametriyle
arkadaşlar
bir fonksiyon var
get fonksiyonu
bakın
charge
while
ifs
get
c
şimdi
ilk bakışta
biraz
belki şaşırtıcı
gibi görünüyor
bunun nasıl
çalıştığını
tahmin edebiliyor
musunuz
cout
good
c
bunun nasıl
çalıştığını
tahmin edebiliyor
musunuz
aslında bu
fonksiyonun
parametresi
yani bu
overload'un
parametresi
char ref
dolayısıyla
okuma başarılı
olduğunda
akım
good state'de
operator
bool fonksiyonu
çağırılıyor
yani bu aslında
ne demek
nokta
operator
bool fonksiyonu
çağır demek
daha önce bahsetmiştim
çünkü geri dönüş
değeri
yıldız test
ama akım
fail olduğu anda
o zaman
operator
bool fonksiyonu
false değer
döndürecek
dolayısıyla
stream
eo
state'e
geçtiğinde
eo
flag
set edildiğinde
döngüden
çıkacak
ben daha çok
bunu kullanıyorum
takip edebildik mi
evet
tabi
aslında ben size
çok hızlı geçtiği için
şöyle
yavaşlatılmış
yavaş çekimde
öyle diyorlar
gösterebilirim
orada
windows'un bana sunduğu
konuya başlık
dosyasındaki
underscore
get.ch
fonksiyonu
bakın şimdi
dosyadan
byte byte okuyorum
en sonuna kadar
gitmeye
gerek yok
anlaşıldı değil mi
byte byte okumak için
sizin
get fonksiyonunu
iki overloaddan
birini
çağırmanız
yeterli
arkadaşlar bunlar
formatsız okuma
fonksiyonları
şimdi
aslında
formatlı okuma
fonksiyonu ile
formatsız okuma
fonksiyonu
arasında
ilginç bir
ne diyelim
fark da var
arkadaşlar
bakınız
çok dikkatli izleyin
şimdi get fonksiyonunu
çağırayım
ondan sonra
sınıfın
gcount fonksiyonunu
çağırayım
ilerleyen zamanda
yine bu
gcount'a
biraz daha
değineceğiz
diyor ki
standart
okuma
iStream
sınıfının
gcount
fonksiyonu
formatsız
bir okuma
işleminden
sonra
çağrıldığı
zaman
okunan
byte sayısını
döndürüyor
tekrar edeyim mi
evet
geri dönüş
değeri
stream size
türünden
dolayısıyla
bakınız
seyahat
eğer burada
bir
değerini
döndürürse
o zaman
get fonksiyonu
formatsız okuma
fonksiyonu
çünkü
gcount
formatsız okuma
fonksiyonlarının
çağrılmasından
sonra
iş görüyor
gördünüz
zaten standart
gcount'un
hangi fonksiyonlar
çağrıldıktan sonra
efendim
okunan
byte sayısını
döndürdüğünü
veriyor
bu arada
aklımızda olsun
diğer get fonksiyonları
için de önemli
arkadaşlar
neden böyle bir şey
yapmışlar biliyor musunuz
şimdi
az önceki örnekte
olduğu gibi
başka get overloadları
da var
get fonksiyonları
ya da
bazı başka
formatsız okuma
fonksiyonları
stream meselesinin
kendisini döndürüyor
bazı fonksiyonlar
dolayısıyla
kaç byte okuduğu
bilgisini
doğrudan
edinemediğiniz için
çünkü fonksiyonun
geri dönüş değeri
örneğin
okunan
byte sayısı
değil
onun için
ne yapmışlar
bir de böyle
gcount fonksiyonu
eklemişler
eğer siz
okuma
işlemi
yalnız bu
formatsız okuma
işlemi için
geçerli
streamden
formatsız okuma
yapıyorsanız
ve
kaç byte
okumdu
sorusunun
cevabını
istiyorsanız
okumayı
yaptıktan sonra
gcount'u
çağıracaksınız
ama gcount
en son yapılan
okuma için
geçerli
arkadaşlar
evet
peki
o zaman
devam edelim
şimdi
bir şey daha
söyleyeyim
çok ilginç
bu fonksiyonu
hatırlıyor musunuz
geçen derste
konuşmuştuk
arkadaşlar
bakın bakın
bu şimdi
çok hoşunuza
geçelim
ifs
readbuff
buraya dikkatli
izleyelim
çünkü
çok hoş
arkadaşlar
bu
r'de
read'den
geliyor
readbuff
ne döndürüyordu
buffer pointer'ı
döndürüyordu
yani
aslında
bu fonksiyon
çağrısından
elde ettiğim
geri dönüş
değeri
streambuff
pointer'ı
ama
ilginç bir şey
var
o readbuff
bazı yerlerde
bir örnekte
readbuff'ı belki
kullanmıştım
hatırlıyorsunuz
bu formatlamayla
ilgili
hatırladınız mı
arkadaşlar
readbuff'ın
geri dönüşleri
olan o
streambuff
pointer'ı
var ya
ilginç bir şekilde
o stream
sınıfının
bir
formatlı
çıkış fonksiyonu
var
yani
inserter'ı
var
ne istiyor
bizden
biliyor musunuz
streambuff
pointer'ı
istiyor
dolayısıyla
bir dosyayı
yazdırmanın
en kolay yolu
aslında
bakın
tek bir
statement
if stream
nesnesinin
ya da
f stream nesnesinin
readbuff
fonksiyonunu
çağırın
ve bu fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerini
operator
left shift'e
argüman
olarak gönderin
böylece
ne yapacak
arkadaşlar
o stream
sınıfının
operator
left shift
fonksiyonu
hangi
overload
aslında şunu
yapıyorum
değil mi
bakınız
seeout
nokta
operator
left shift
overloadlara
operator
left shift
overloadlara
bakarsanız
bakın bakın
işte
daha birinci
sırada çıktı
ne diyor
rasul
parametresi
streambuff
yıldız
bu fonksiyonu
diyor ki
eğer diyor
bana bir
buffer pointer'ı
verirsen
o buffer'daki
karakterlerin
hepsini
stream'e
veririm
diyor
dolayısıyla
siz
ifs'nin
readbuff fonksiyonundan
buffer pointer'ını
alıp
bu fonksiyonu
argüman olarak
geçerseniz
şu parantezde
kaldırayım
dosyayı
arkadaşlar
o stream'e
yazdırmış
olursunuz
anlaşıldı
anlaşıldı mı
şimdi
formatlı
giriş
çıkış
işlemlerini
doğrudan
anlatmıyorum
çünkü
hepsini
biliyoruz
ama
mesela
bundan
sonraki
örneklerde
işimizi
görsün
diye
gelin
birkaç
tane
dosya
oluşturalım
arkadaşlar
bakınız
benim
nutridi
h içinde
eğer
adem
duruyorsa
asal sayı
test
fonksiyonum
vardı
ismi
isprime
bakın geldi
mesela
öyle bir şey
yapmak istiyorum ki
bir dosyaya
arkadaşlar
en tane
ilk en tane
asal sayıyı
formatlı olarak
yazdırmak istiyorum
izleyin
offstream
türünden
bir nesne
dosyanın
ismi
rhymes
nokta
txt
olsun
arkadaşlar
efendim
asal
test edilecek
sayı
x
olsun
bir tane
sayı
değişken
alayım
int
prime
count
yazma
işlemini gösteren
aslında çok
güzel bir
konu
izleyin
şimdi
while
prime
count
efendim
küçüktür
arkadaşlar
hatta
biraz daha güzel
yapalım
izleyin
bakın
çok güzel bir program
beraber yazın
izleyin
şimdi
kaç asal sayı
c
in
n
o string
stream
öğrendiğimiz her şeyi
neredeyse
kullanacağız
bakın
s stream
başlık dosyasını
ayin ediyorum
o string stream
tabi format
kıtmanesiyle
bunu daha kolay
yaparım
aslında
efendim
c++20 ile
o string stream
o s
primes
arkadaşlar
set ve
o
olmasın
primes
n
dot
t
dolayısıyla
şimdi
elde edeceğim
yazı
primes
bin
nokta
t
primes
beş
bin
nokta
t
o
şekilde
olacak
ve
şimdi
dosyanın
ismini elde
etmek
için
tahmin
edin
daha önce
öğrenmiştik
geçen
haftalarda
ofs'nin
str
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
oss'nin
bana bunu
bir yazı olarak
döndürüyor ya
tamam
oss
bir değişkende
de tutabilirdim
oss
str
dosyası
oluşturulamadı
ingilizce
ingilizce yazımı
böyle
cannot
create
file
oss
str
en acil
olacak
izleyin
bundan sonrası
çok basit
artık
exit
failure
kalsın
tamam
prime count
küçük
arkadaşlar
n
if
is prime
x
o fs
set ve
diyelim ki
x
ve bir boşluk
özellikle bazı şeyleri
baştan
istemediğim
şekilde yazıyorum ki
neden bazı öyeleri
kullandığımı
iyi anlayın diye
evet
efendim ondan sonra
artı artı
prime count
x
bakın dosyayı
kapatmak için
bir çaba göstermiyorum
bir şey yapmıyorum
neden
çünkü
destructor dosyayı
kapatacak
burayı anladık mı
x asal
ise
arkadaşlar
10 karakterlik
alana
x'i
ne yaptım
yazdım
ama şimdi
hiç new line
vermedim
değil mi
yani
izleyin
ilk kaç asal sayı
ilk
100 asal sayı
bakın şimdi
dosyaya
add
existing item
primes
nokta
txt
ve
dosyayı açıyorum
neden böyle
e çünkü
hiç new line
yazmadım ki
ama bakın
arkadaşlar
şuraya
bir kod daha
ekleyeyim
if
prime count
sıfır
değilse
ve
prime count'un
diyelim ki
ona bölümünden kalan
sıfırsa
ofs
new line
ya da
ofs'e put
new line
da olurdu
öylece
her 10
asal sayı
yazdığında
bir
sonraki
satıra
geçecek
yani new line
verecek
ilk kaç asal
sayı
şimdi izleyin
dosya
zaten açık
gördünüz değil mi
arkadaşlar
evet formatlı
bir şekilde
yazdım ama
ben
biraz
daha büyük
dosya
oluşturmak
istiyorum
şunların hepsi
kalsın
bir zararı yok
ilk 5 bin
asal sayı
ilk
20 bin
asal sayı
ilk
arkadaşlar
1 milyon
asal sayı
3 4 5 6
debug modundaysa
ağır çalışır
yok release modundaymış
yok 1 milyon
olmadı
10 milyon
3 0
3 0 daha
evet
ilk 1 milyon
asal sayı
yazdı
evet o
daha fazla yapmayalım
bakalım
ilk 1 milyon
asal sayı
içeren
dosyamızı
editörde
açalım
edit
prime
1 milyon
nokta
tx'de
açmakta
biraz zorlanıyor
ve
açtı
bakıyoruz
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
ilk
1 milyon
asal sayı
şimdi bundan
okuma işlemleri de
yapabiliriz
formatlı okuma
interfezini de
burada ne yapabiliriz
görebiliriz
evet bir ara verelim
saat 21.01
21.20'de
devam ediyoruz
arkadaşlar
dosyadan
formatlı okuma da
yine
operator
write
fonksiyonu ile
yapılacak
mesela
dosyadan
şimdi
tam sayı
okumak istersek
tıpkı
standart
input'tan
okur gibi
şöyle
evet
ifstream
nesnemizi
oluşturalım
ifstream
ifs
diyelim ki
dosyamızın
ismi
primes
100.txt
bakın herhangi bir
open mode
türünden
herhangi bir
flag
vermiyorum
çünkü
tek istediğim
in
binary'yi de
istemiyorum
text modunda
okuyacağım
yine de
kontrolümü
yapayım
if
deal
ifs
crd
cannot
open
file
return
şimdi
int
x
while
ifs
bakılıyorsunuz
değil mi
x
ne zaman
fail
olursa
operator
boğul
fonksiyonu
false
döndürecek
döngüden
çıkacak
sıra dışı
bir neden
olmazsa
fail
olmasının
nedeni
eof
state'e
geçmesi
olacak
ve
burada
diyelim ki
cout
x
sonuna
kadar
bekleyecek
diyelim
underscore
gece
a
evet
bakın
dosyadan
ben her bir tuşa
bastığımda
bir tane
tam sayıyı
okuyor
bin yokmuş
sanırım
beş bin
vardı
arkadaşlar
şimdi bakın
bir iki tane
basit uygulama
yapalım
mesela çok
klasik
mülakatlarda
sorulan
soru
dosyadaki
asker
fark
karakterlerinin
sayısını
bulmak
izleyin
bu sefer
standart
input
manu
to
see
out
enter
file
name
to
string
name
file name
see
in
hadi
şunları da
şimdilik
yazmayalım
see
in
file name
ipstream
ipse
file name
if
ifs
fail
crr
cannot
open
file
return
şimdi bu dosyadaki
karakter karakteri okuyayım
dosyayı
arkadaşlar
int
c
while
eşittir
ifs'nin
get'i
eşit
olmadığı
sürece
eo
evet
şimdi
ya da
şöyle de
yazabilirdim
char c
ifs
get
c
arkadaşlar
bunu bir
map
tutalım
videomunu hatırlıyorsunuz
map'in
char virgül
int açılımı
map başlık dosyasını dahil ediyorum
map'in
char virgül
int açılımı
c map
sayma amaçlı kullanacağım
köşeli parantez
c
artı artı
ama
buraya bir de
test kodu koyalım
if
is alpha
siz standart silik
kütüphanesinden
geliyor biliyorsunuz
is alpha c
park karakteri ise
topper
c
şimdi artık
map'teki
bölüleri
yazdırabilirim
or
const
auto
ladder
count
structure
binding
c
map
out
ladder
count
programlamayla ilgili genel
plakat sorularında çok sorularmış
sonra böyle
lead code
arasında
değerleyip çalıştıralım
şunu kapatalım
evet
main.gpp
can not open file
bir dakika orada bir yanlışlık yok değil mi
string file name
scene file name
if stream file name
fail olmuşsa
iyi o zaman
bir dakika
a
out
nokta
txt
arkadaşlar buraya file name yazmışım
yani
bir chat ekranında da okumuyorum
evet
arkadaşlar da yazmış
ben de tam size topu atacaktım
niye bana söylemiyorsunuz diye
string literarı yazmışım
komediye bakın
file name
olsun
olur böyle şeyler
evet
şimdi herhalde
eksik bir şey kalmadı
iki arkadaşım yazmış
ben farkında değilim
main.gpp
evet
a'dan 24 tane
c'den 26 tane
d'den 8 tane
efendim şimdi de
hatta şöyle
büyükten küçüğe yazdırmıştık
hatırlıyor musunuz
onu da tekrar
buraya koyalım
vektör
başlık dosyasını
dahil ediyorum
vektörün
pair'in
char virgül
int açılımı
vek
cmap'in
begin'i
range constructor
cmap'in
end'i
algoritm başlık dosyasını
ekliyorum
stutsort
vek begin
vek end
lambda ifadesi
const
auto
ref
e1
pair'in
const
auto
ref
e2
return
e1
nokta
second
arkadaşlar
büyük'tür
p2
nokta
second
oldu sanırım
ama yazdırırken
vektörü yazdırır
örneğin
çalıştıralım
enter file name
örneğin
ne olsun
main.cpp
evet
49 tane
e
43 tane
n
40 tane
c
karakteri
varmış
bir tane
daha
yapalım
utility
nokta
h
daha büyük
dosya
en fazla
e karakteri
varmış
tane
sonra
a karakteri
tane
öyle gidiyor
arkadaşlar bu arada
bakın bu
ilginç
modern c++'a
eklenen bazı
özellikler var
şimdi normalde
bu
string stream
sınıfları
için de
geçerli
bu anlattığım
normalde
operator
left
chip
operator
right
chip
fonksiyonları
yani formatlı
okuma
formatlı
yazma
fonksiyonları
bunların
parametresinin
n value
referansı
olması
gerekiyor
yani
r value
geçtiğimiz zaman
syntax
hatası
oluyordu
ama sonra
bunların
r value
overloadlarını
da eklediler
bu ne demek
yani şöyle bir
kodu bile
yazabiliyorsunuz
bakın
upstream
temporary
object
emirhan
tx'de
diyelim ki
emirhan
arkadaşlar
çelik
bu
sentars
hatası yok
yani
geçi
nesne
oluşturdum
upstream
sınıfı
türünden
ve
ona
dosyayı
açtım
açtığım
dosyaya da
emirhan
çelik
yazdım
geçi
nesne
olduğu için
destructor
çağrıldı
da
dosyayı
arkadaşlar
kapattı
yine benzer
şekilde
buraya kadar
bir görelim
arkadaşlar
evet
çalıştırıyorum
emirhan.tx'i
açıyorum
evet
içeriğine
bakalım
emirhan.tx'de
gördüğünüz gibi
gerçekten
dosya var
hatta
bakın
şimdi
adem
dosyayı
açtık
emirhan.tx'de
on iki
kırk beş
doksan sekiz
hatta buradan
okuma da yapabilirim
ya da şöyle yazalım
arkadaşlar
bunu bir yazı olarak
yazalım
on iki
kırk beş
altmış
yedi
doksan
şimdi de
yine
r
value'le
çalıştığını
göstermek için
if stream
benimki
ilk sayı
okumam
gerekiyor
x
int x
bazı yerlerde
işe yarıyor
hani çok da
önemli bir özellik mi
çok seyrek de olsa
bazı yerlerde
r value
kullanmanın
sağlayacağı
bir takım
faydalar olabiliyor
bu stream
nesneleri için
evet
x'in değerini
yazdıralım
evet
arkadaşlar
bu stream
nesnelerinin
okumaya
topyalamaya
karşı kapalı
taşımaya
karşı açık
olduğunu
hatırlayalım
dolayısıyla
taşıma
semantinden
faydalanarak
mesela
dosyayı
oluşturma
açma
gibi
işlemleri
fonksiyonlara
yaptırabilirsiniz
mesela
bakınız
open
utility
dosyamda
bunun
benzeri
olduğu için
camel case
kullanıyorum
isim çakışması
olmasın
open text file
const
string
ref
fname
dosyanin
ismini
alacak
o dosyayı
text dosyası
okuma
amaçlı
arkadaşlar
open text file
read
geri dönüş
değeri
stut
if stream
bakın referans
stut
if stream
biraz daha özelleştireceğim
ifs
fname
if
bein
ifs
sefer
exception
throw
etsin
stut
runtime
error
can not
open
file
fname
buraya bakın
şimdi
asıl espri
burada
tabi
dosyayı
hex modunda
açtım
return
ifs
x value
transformation
oldu
normalde
kopyalama yasak
ama burada
taşıma semantiydi
evreye girdi
mesela
bakınız
auto
ifs
eşittir
open
text file
read
main.jpp
cout
ipse
read
poplar
doğru çalıştığını göstermek için basit bir kod yazdım
derdik çalıştırıyorum
herhangi bir şekilde bir problem olmadı
şimdi
main
iki nokta
jpp
exception
provide
check
exception
yakalayacağım
şimdi biraz
binary modda açmaya da bakalım
burada return value optimization var mı
hayır hayır
burada return value optimization
yok
burada taşıma
semantiyinden faydalanıyor
yani buradaki yerel nesneyi
taşıyorum
evet
zaten
yani buna return value optimization
diyebilir miyim
doğrudan değil
evet
çünkü bu kopyalamaya karşı
kapatılmış bir sınıf türünden nesneyi
aynı şekilde
mesela böyle
yazma amaçlı da yapabilirdim
mesela
şunun bir benzerini yazalım
bu sefer
off stream döndürsün
open text file
write olsun
ismi
off stream
ops
can not create file
auto auto vs
open text file
write
main 2
nokta
txt
ya da
out nokta txt
açık zaten
return
o vs
it
evet
ve alt nokta txt'ye
bakıyoruz
arkadaşlar
Alihan Bozkari
lvalue to xvalue
yapıyor
evet buradaki dönüşüme
standart
lvalue to
xvalue
transformation
diyor
şimdi dosyanın
binary modda
açılmasına bakalım
arkadaşlar dosyayı
binary
ha bu arada bir şey daha
göstermek istiyorum
bakın bakın
mesela
şu
at
and
bayran
bayranı da
görelim
izleyin
bir dosyayı açalım
if stream
if
bir nedenden dolayı
dosya konumu göstericisini
dosyanın sonunda
açacaksınız
olacak şekilde
mesela dosyanın
size'ını elde etmek
için
primes
100.txt
izleyin
dosya açılacak
burayı geçiyorum
fakat
bayrak olarak
iOS'un
open
open mode'unun
arkadaşlar
etendi
cout
pi pointer'ın
değerini get etmek
için telge
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
ifs
telge
geri dönüş
değeri
tam sayı
stream
postöründen
böylece
dosyada
kaç byte var
onu
yazdırmış
oluyorum
hatta
şöyle yazdım
by
size
arkadaşlar
şimdi
bilmeyenler için
söylüyorum
bir önceki
derste
halen
derste mi
arkadaşım
Yiğit
bakıyoruz
evet
dersteymiş
Yiğit
bana bir soru
sormuştu
hatırlıyor musunuz
text modunda
açmakla
binary modda
açmak
arasındaki
fark
okuma ve
yazma
işlemlerinde
bakın
ben de şu anda
Windows işletim sistemi
olduğu için
gösterebilirim
şimdi bakın
önce
bu 1310
davasını
gösterelim
şu anda
dosyayı
text modunda
açtım
izleyin
dosyaya
100 kez dönen
bir döngüde
Newline
yazıyorum
arkadaşlar
izleyin
hatta
şu dosyanın
uzantısı
evet
alt nokta
dat olsun
açmayacağım
zaten
bakın
dosyayı
text modunda
açtım
şimdi izleyin
dosyayı
bulalım
open
containing
folder
out
nokta
adapt
aslında
görüyorsunuz
bakın şu küçük
yazı okunuyor mu
bilmiyorum
sizin ekranda
200 byte
diyor ama
özelliklere
bakıp
onu görebilirsiniz
ben şuradan
görüyorum
zaten
200 byte
zaman kazanalım
arkadaşlar
evet
gördünüz değil mi
dosyanın
büyüklüğü
200 byte
evet
ama şimdi bakın
şunu kapatayım
tekrar
eğer
dosyayı
binary modda
açsaydım
neden
200 byte
oldu
çünkü
100 tane
yazdı
öyle değil mi
ama bakın
şimdi dosyadan
okuma yapıyorum
şöyle bir kodla
int c
orada
dosyayı
kapatayım
ofs
close
ifstream
ifs
out
noktada
arkadaşlar
int c
y
c
eşittir
ifs'nin
geti
arkadaşlar
eşit olmadığı sürece
e of
c
out
arkadaşlar
aslında 1310
var bakın okurken
diye okuyor
ama şimdi dosyayı
binary modda
açıyorum
ios'un
binary'si
şimdi artık
1310 çiftini
ve 10 olarak
okuyacak
10 olarak
okumayacak
yani 1310'u
newline olarak
almayacak
yiğit'in dediği
farklılıklardan
biri buydu
aynı şekilde
bakınız
bu sefer
yazarken
arkadaşlar
binary modda
açıyorum
yani yazma amaçlı
dosyayı
ios
binary
şimdi
olarak mı
yazacak
yoksa
100 tane
10 mu
yazacak
cevap
100 tane
10 yazacak
bu birincisi
ikincisi
bu 26'ın
oğlu karakter
onu da gösterelim
arkadaşlar bu kez
dosyaya
dosyayı
açtım
100 tane
diyelim ki
a karakteri
yazayım
küçük harf a
ondan sonra
ofs
arkadaşlar
26 değerini
yazayım
takip edebiliyor muyuz
ama
performanssız
o vs
yani
ctrl z
karakterini
yazacağım
evet
o vs
mut
ondan sonra
da
diyelim ki
100 tane
b
karakteri
yazayım
şimdi ben
bu dosyayı
hex modunda
açtığımda
byte byte okuma
yaptığımda
a'ları
okuyacak
ama
b'leri
okumayacak
devamlı siz
evde yazarsınız
oysa
binary modda
açtığımda
26'yı da
okuyacak
yani
text modunda
açarsam
bu da çok
tehlikeli
değil mi
bakın mesela
bir imaj dosyasını
okuyorsunuz
orada
26'nın
dosya sonu
vs.
gibi bir anlamı
yok
bir
exe dosya
bir imaj dosyası
yani binary
herhangi bir dosya
tesadüfen
bir byte'ın
değeri
26'ysa
arkadaşlar
o zaman
ona
dosya sonu
muamelesi
yapıyor
dolayısıyla
bakın
iki tane
koşul
bir
bir kere
dosyanın
text değişikli
alakası yoksa
her zaman
dosyayı
binary modda
açın
iki
dosya
üstünde
yapacağınız
işlem
dosyanın
text dosyası
ya da
binary dosya
olmasından
bağımsızsa
o zaman da
yine
binary modda
açın
ama
text dosyası
üstünde
text işlemi
yapacaksanız
o zaman
dosyayı
text modunda
açın
şimdi gelelim
binary'ye
arkadaşlar bakın
son derece
basit burası
iki tane
fonksiyon var
fonksiyonlardan
biri
yine
taban sınıfın
read fonksiyonu
formatsız
okuma yapıyor
diğeri de
taban sınıfın
write fonksiyonu
bunlar artık
karakter kodlarını
yazmıyor
yani
tıpkı
c'deki
every
def write
fonksiyonları
gibi
bunlar
dosyadan
ram'e
ram'den
dosyaya
transfer yapıyor
yani artık
yazdığımız
ya da okuduğumuz
doğrudan
byte'ların
kendisi
arkadaşlar
bir örnek verelim
bakın
bir önce
yazdığımız
kodu
hani
bir milyon tane
asal sayı
yazmıştık ya
bu sefer
bir milyon tane
asal sayı
binary olarak
yazılmıyor
o zaman
dosyanın
büyüklüğünün
kaç byte
olduğu baştan
belli değil mi
nasıl belli
ya son derece
basit
bir milyon
size of int
dört olduğuna
göre
bir milyon
tane tam sayı
yazarsam
dosyanın
büyüklüğünün
dört milyon
olması lazım
öyle değil mi
izleyin
offstream
ofs
alt nokta
txt
oyoz
binary
kesinlikle
binary modda
açmalıyım
şimdi
alt olmasın
ismi
txt
de olmasın
uzantısı
sırtlaktın
tekstolojistası
ne değil
times
nokta
dot
izleyin
int x
int
ram count
int x
while
hatta x'i iki değeriyle başlatalım yine
prime count
küçük
küçük tutalım
dosyayı
yüz bin
if
is prime
x
x asal sayısa
bakın bakın şimdi
sınıfın
right
fonksiyonu
buraya dikkat
biraz
burası
belki
topumuzu
karıştırabilir
arkadaşlar bakın şimdi
right fonksiyonunun
birinci parametresi
akımın
karakteri
türünden
pointer
ikinci parametresi
kaç byte
okuma
ya da yazma için
yazma tarafında da
okuma tarafında da
kaç byte
sorusunun cevabı
mesela ben
burada
x'in
byte'larını
dosyaya yazacağıma göre
fonksiyonun
ikinci parametresine
ne
geçmeliyim
cevap
size of int
geçmeliyim
fonksiyonun
birinci
dört
tabii bu
sisteme bağlı
ya alian
o yüzden söylüyorum
o yüzden size of int
dedim
fonksiyonun
birinci parametresine
yalnız burada
dikkat
hatta ben bu örneği
şöyle söylüyorum
reinterpret
cast
operatörünün
kullanılması
zorunlu olan
sayılı
senaryolardan
biri
yani normalde
c olsaydı
c'de
void pointer
değil mi
every defride
fonksiyonlarının
o adres
parametresi
c dilinde
void pointer
dolayısıyla herhangi
türden bir adres
gönderebiliyorum
ama dikkat ederseniz
buradaki
read write
fonksiyonlarının
parametresi
stream'in
o template
parametresi olan
karakter türü
yani bizim
stream'imiz için
bu
char
dolayısıyla
aslında benim
adres x
vermem lazım
x'in adresinden
başlayarak
size of
int
byte'lık
blogdan
bir tane
bu kadar
byte yaz
ama derleyici
sentax hatası
verecek
neden
sentax hatası
verecek
çünkü
fonksiyonun
parametresi
char
yıldız
ama ben ona
int
yıldız
gönderiyorum
bu durumda
mecbur ne
yapıyorum
reinterpret
cast
operatörünü
kullanıyorum
argüman olarak
arkadaşlar
char
yıldız
türüne
test etmesi
için
neyi
x'in
adresini
takip edebildik mi
evet
her yazdığım
asal sayı için
prime
count'u
bir arttırayım
ve
if'in dışında da
x'i arttırayım
evet
bakın şimdi
dosyanın ismi
primes.dat
hemen
primes.dat'ın
büyüklüğüne
bakıyoruz
eğer biz
kodda bir hata
yapmamışsak
400.000
olması gerekiyor
değil mi
aksi bir ihtimal
söz konusu değil
çünkü
her asal sayı için
4 byte yazdım
100.000 tane asal sayı için
400.000 byte yazmış
olmalıyım
evet
open
containing
folder
primes.dat
arkadaşlar
görüyorsunuz
aşağıda da
gösteriyor
şurada özelliklerden de
gösterir zaten
çok küçük
okuyamayabilirsiniz
ben okuyorum
boyut
400.000 byte
imlecin olduğu yer
anlaşıldı
değil mi
dolayısıyla
binary yazım
son derece
basit
write fonksiyonuna
çağrı yapıyorum
birinci parametresine
ramdeki
adresi
yazıyorum
ve
argüman olarak
veriyorum
ikinci parametresine
arkadaşlar
yazılacak
byte sayısı
mesela bakınız
bu illa
bu şekilde
olması gerekmiyor
elimizde bir
vektör var
hadi bir örnek
yapalım
şu
burası
kalsın
bu sefer
dosyamızın
ismi
neco.dat
olsun
bu kalsın
burada
bizim
notility'de
bir sürü yardımcı
fonksiyonumuz
vardı
bakın
vektörün
int açılımı
ivek
random
field
hatırlayalım
şimdi
birinci
parametresi
arkadaşlar
container
ivek
ikinci
parametresi
sayı
sanırım
diyelim ki
arkadaşlar
10.000
üçüncü
parametresi
generator
irent
binle
9.999
arasında
ama yanlış anlaşılmasın
basamak değerleri
irent
sıfırla
1 milyon
arasında
ya da
10 milyon
arasında
değerler
şimdi
vektörün
sayısı
kaç
vektörün
sayısı
10.000
o zaman
bu vektörde
bunlar
ardışık
olarak duruyor
değil mi
kesinlikle
peki
vektörün
o allocate
ettiği
berlek bloğunun
adresini
sınıfın
data
fonksiyonuna
çağrı yaparak
elde edebilirim
değil mi
dolayısıyla
bakınız
ibeg.data
zaten
benim adresim
ee
diyelim ki
size'ını
bilmesem dahi
ben size'ını
biliyorum ama
ibeg'in
size'ı
arkadaşlar
çarpı
size of
int
ne yapacağım
tahmin ettiniz mi
doğrudan
dosyaya yazacağım
bakın
ofs
write
static
cast
aslında
int
yıldız
static
cast
çağrı
yıldız
ibeg'in
datası
static
kest
diyorum
reinterpret
kest
evet
bakın
birinci
parametresine
allocate
edilmiş
bellek
bloğunun
adresini
geçtim
o sınıfın
data fonksiyonunun
o adresi
döndürdüğünü
hatırlayalım
ikinci
parametre
ama tabi
o adresi
geçerken
fonksiyonun
parametresi
çağrı yıldız
olduğu için
adresi
reinterpret
cast
operatörüyle
çağrı yıldız
türüne
kestettim
ikinci parametre
dosyaya kaç byte
yazılacağı
değeriydi
o da
vektörün
size'ı
size fonksiyonuyla
get ediyorum
onu size of
int ile çarpıp
byte sayısı
olarak
argüman olarak
geçtim
ve şimdi
dosyada
kapandı
destructörümüzde
dosyayı
kapattı
ben sadece size
neyi göstereceğim
neco nokta
dat
aslında
on bin çarpı
dört
kırk bin
byte'lık
bir dosya
olması lazım
çünkü
formatsız
yazdım
ama aman
dikkat
ay olsun
binary flagini
eklemeyi
unutmuyoruz
evet
arkadaşlar
izleyin
prince.dat
özellikler
evet
bakın
tam
dört yüz bin
byte
şimdi
okuma tarafına
gelecek olursak
arkadaşlar
neco nokta
dat
değil mi
yanlış mı
gösterdim
open
containing
folder
değiştirme
tarihi
arkadaşlar
neco nokta
dat
evet
niye çıkmadı
demin
ya da ben mi
yanlış gösterdim
değiştirme
evet
varmış
buradaymış
işte
neco nokta
dat
özellikler
dört yüz bin
byte
kırk bin byte
dört yüz bin
değil
evet
kırk bin
on bin
çarpı
dört
kırk bin
şimdi okuma tarafına
gelelim
bakın
bu da çok
önemli
okuma tarafı
içinde
arkadaşlar
read
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
evet
yalnız bu arada
dikkat
bakın
write read
fonksiyonlarının
geri dönüş
değeri
yine
stream
nesnesi
dolayısıyla
okuyamadığı zaman
hemen
read fonksiyonu
da göstereyim
neyse
dosyayı açalım
ifstream
ifs
neco nokta
dat
ifs
neco dat
dosyası
açılamadı
evet
şimdi
diyelim ki
bu dosyada
binary olarak
yazılmış
tam sayılar var
ben bunları
tek tek
okumak istiyorum
arkadaşlar
şimdi
bakınız
ben
read fonksiyonunu
çağırdığım zaman
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerinin
yine
ne olduğunu
görüyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
istream
ref olduğunu
görüyorsunuz
dolayısıyla
şöyle bir döngüde
while
ifs
read fonksiyonu
bu sefer de
hons
çağır yıldız
değil
çünkü
benim verdiğim
adrese
dosyadan
okunulan
byte'ları
doğrudan
yazacak
yalnız
bu tür durumlarda
neye de
dikkat etmemiz
gerekiyor
Yusuf
örneğin
okuyan taraf
little ending
yazan taraf
big ending
ise
orada dönüşüm
yapmanız
gerekiyor
şimdi bizde
öyle bir problem
olmadığı için
doğrudan
okuyabiliriz
ben bir değişken
aldım
int x
arkadaşlar
izleyin
evet
ifs
read
birinci
parametresini
reinterpret
cast
evet
reinterpret
cast
int yıldız
çağır yıldız
özür dilerim
adres
x
kaç byte okuyacak
bu seferde
okuma
kaç byte okuyacak
size of
int
byte okuyacak
böylece artık
döngünler turunda
benim
x nesnemi
set ettiği için
onun değerini
formatlı olarak
yazdırabilirim
see out
x
rastgele tam sayılar
yazmıştık ya
underscore
geçe ya
yani
korumansız okuma
yazma
aslında son derece
basit
evet
e şimdi
burası çok geniş bir konu
deniz
yani
şimdi
bütün bu yazdıklarım
bütün bu yazdığım
kodlar
çar türünün
karakter türü
olması
ve bizim
code page'imize göre
yani
ASCII karakterlerine göre
dolayısıyla
örneğin şimdi
türkçe karakterleri
okuyup yazsaydık
okuma yazma tarafında
doğrudan
bunu kullanamayacaktık
şimdi o kısmı
baya bir konuşmak
gerekiyor
evet
yani
unicode olarak mı
okuyacaksınız
code page'i mi
değiştireceksiniz
biz şimdilik
böyle gidelim
evet bakın
sıfırla bir milyon
arasındaydı ya
bunlar
dosyaya yazan
selamlar
zaten
asal sayı örneğine de
bakın
primes.dat
bakın bakın şimdi
kodu hiç değiştirmiyorum
bunu kapatmadım
ben her tuşa bastığımda
dosyadan
biraz
asal sayı yok
arkadaşlar
yalnız bakın bir
yanlışlık olmasın
şöyle de yapabilirim
gelin ilginç bir şey
yapalım şimdi
dosyadan birer birer
okumak zorunda
şüphesiz değilim
mesela
izleyin
benim bir vektörüm var
vektörün
int açılımı
ivek
burayı özellikle dikkatli
izleyelim
ve vektörü
diyelim ki
ne olsun
10'u ve ile başlatayım
bu bir dizide
olabilirdi
şimdi
döngünün her turunda
şu anda vektörün
size'ı 10
yine datayı
argüman olarak
veriyorum
ivek
data
ama size of int
çarpı
böylece döngünün
her turunda
vektörün
o elemanları
tutmak için
allocate ettiği
bellek alanına
dosyadan
size of int
çarpı
10 byte
transfer edecek
dolayısıyla
şimdi ben
arkadaşlar
vektörü
10 elemanlı
bu vektörü
bu normal
cd'si de
olabilirdi
dolaşıp
yazdırdığımda
işte
sırasıyla
ilk 10 asal sayı
ikinci 10 asal sayı
böyle
gidecekti
değil mi
hatta şöyle yapalım
constexper
size t
size
eşittir
şuraya da
size'ı koyalım
zaten bizim
bir fonksiyonumuz vardı
container'ı yazdıran
print
jprint
miydi ismi
ben de unuttum
neyse
o zaman
madem
unuttuk
copy
algoritması
yazdım
copy
ebek
şuraya
size
size yazmayı
unutmayın
evet
copy
ebek
begin
end
o stream
literatür
arkadaşlar
int açılımı
cout
öce döngünler turunda
vektöre
size tane
öeyi
dosyadan okudum
vektörün
berle kalanına
ve onları
standart
alt kuta
yazdırdım
bu sefer
getkarı
çağıralım ki
new line versin
evet
bakın şu anda
on
bakın ilk on
ikinci on
her tuşa bastığımda
dosyadan
size of pin
çarpı
on byte
vektörün
bellek alanına
ne yapıyor
arkadaşlar
göre
biraz şimdi
n değerini
on değerini
değiştirelim
mesela
yüz yapalım
bu sefer
yüzer yüzer
okuyacak
arkadaşlar
back
insurter'e yapılan
çağrıyla
vektöre
onar
ekleyebilir
miyiz
evet ama
Alihan
onu yapmanız
için
yani
eğer
vektöre
sürekli
onları
okumak
istiyorsanız
o zaman
o adresi
elde etmeniz
gerekiyor
o adresi
tabii ki
elde edebilirsiniz
pointer aritmetiyle
şimdi kodu yazmayacağım
ama ne demek istediğimi
anlıyorsunuz
değil mi
evet
vektördeki
eleman sayısını
arttırmanız
gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
back insurter'la
değil ama
o adresi
her zaman
yazılacak yerin
adresini
vermeniz gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
şimdi
benim
C kursunda
örnek olarak
yazdığım
bir kod var
gayet de güzel
konuyla da
son derece
ilgili
bir sınıf
çalışması
gerçi zamanımız
az kalmış
ama bir dahaki
derste
devam ederiz
arkadaşlar
şöyle bir örnek
istiyorum
bir dosyayı
parçalara
ayıracak
ve
bir başka
programda
parçalara
ayrılmış
dosyayı
birleştirecek
komut satırından
çalışacak
diyelim ki
komut baştan sona
en azından
yok 20 dakika
var yazarız
gibi görünüyor
komut satırından
örneğin
şöyle
çalıştırılsın
arkadaşlar
böl dosyayı
çünkü
aynı örneği
başka sınıflarda
C kodu olarak
yazdığım için
aynı direktörüyü
kullanacağım
isim çakışması
olmasın
böl dosyayı
örneğin
ali nokta
dot
bin
arkadaşlar
bu şekilde
çalıştırdığım zaman
birinci komut
satırı
argümanı
yani buradaki
böl dosyayı
dosyanın ismi
ali nokta
dot
parçalara bölünecek
dosyanın ismi
üçüncü
komut satır
argümanı
yani
ar
g v
bu da
dosyanın
o parçalara
böleceğim ya
her bir parçadaki
arkadaşlar
byte sayısı
yani örneğin
ali nokta
dot
eğer
12 bin
byte ise
12 tane
bin
byte'lık
dosya
oluşturacak
ama
13.
dosyanın
uzamlığı
byte
olacak
yani
bizim
ali nokta
adı atı
13 tane
biner
byte'lık
tabii en sonuncusu
bin byte
olmayacak
neye bölüyor
dosyaya bölüyor
ondan sonra
bir program
daha yazacağız
bu programda
ismi
bir
dos olsun
o da
bu parçaları
birleştirecek
bizden sadece
komut satırı
argümanı olarak
yeni dosyanın
ismini isteyecek
yani
ali nokta
dotı
bin byte'lık
parçalara
bölmüştük ya
bir dos
beli nokta
dot
diye
çalıştırdığımda
bu sefer de
o
bin byte'lık
parçaları
birleştirip
12 bin
bu örnek için
byte'lık
veli nokta
dot
dosyasını
oluşturacağım
arkadaşlar
yalnız
şöyle bir şey
istiyorum
burada
o parça
dosyalarının
ismini
biz
kendi
formatımıza
göre
oluşturacağız
ki
şöyle bir
format
olsun
mesela
parça
nokta
par
işte bu
yukarıdaki örnek
için
bin byte olacak
parça
par
bin byte
olacak
hepsini yazmıyorum
bu durumda
parça
par
o da
byte olacak
diğer programda
bunları birleştirip
dosyayı
eski haline
ama başka
isimli bir dosya
olarak
birleştirecek
yani mesela
bir taraf parçaya
ayırıp
network üstünden
gönderiyor
diğer tarafta
onları
birleştiriyor
bu amaçla
kullanılabilir
arkadaşlar
burada
ben herkesin
komut satırı
argümanları
İngilizcesiyle
command line
arguments
konusunda
o
c'de de
aynı şekilde
kullanıldığı için
bildiğini varsayarak
kodu yazacağım
anlaştık mı
command line
arguments
peki
şimdi
önce bazı
şunlar kalsın
evet
baştan sona
takip etmeye çalışın
ve benim
yanlış bir kod
yazdığımı
düşünürseniz
doğru
haklı olun
ya da olmayın
mutlaka
chat ekranına
yazın
ben de
arada oraya
bakayım
int main
int
arp c
char
yıldız
argv
bu arada
samimi olarak
eleştirmek için
tabii ki
söylemiyorum
olabilir
bilmeyenler
command line
arguments
konusunu
yani işte
burada örneğin
main fonksiyonunun
parametreleri
bunlar nedir
nasıl çalışıyor
arkada neler oluyor
bu konuyu
daha önce
öğrenmemiş olan
arkadaşım varsa
söylesin
evet
normalde
c'de
anlatıyorum
ama
kendiniz
öğrenmişsinizdir
büyük ihtimalle
öğrenmediyseniz de
bu konunun
anlaşılması için
bir problem
oluşturmuyor
röslü demiş ki
derin bilmiyorum
ama kullanabiliyorum
o da
şimdilik yeterli
evet
arkadaşlar
şimdi
söyleyin bakalım
arcsinin
bu arada
şunların artık
aynı anlama
geldiğini
pointer
notasyonu
böyle de olur
bu şekilde yazılabileceğini
biliyorsunuz değil mi
yan çar yıldız
rgb
boş köşeli
parantez
yazmakla
böyle yazmak
aynı anlamda
ben ikinciyi
tercih ediyorum
deniz de demiş ki
ben haberdarım ama
sık sık kullanmamı
gerektirecek bir şeyim
olmadı
aslında
hani programların
çoğu
özellikle bu
unix
nüx kökenli
sistemlerde
komut satırından
çalıştırıldığı için
bilmekte
fayda var
arkadaşlar
program
böl dos
halitat
bin
şeklinde
çağrıldığına göre
rgc'nin
kaç olması
gerekir
alian
arcsinin
kaç olması
gerekir
cevap
o yüzden önce
kontrolümü
yapıyorum
arcs
eşit
değilse
o zaman
kullanıcının
programı
yanlış çalıştırma
girişiminde
bulunduğunu
anlıyorum
hata akımına
stud
crr
iostream
başlık dosyasını
ekleyelim
gerektikçe
başlık dosyalarını
ekleyeceğim
stud
crr
efendim
usage
gerçi
programın
ismi
Türkçe
yazı da
olsun
kullanım
arkadaşlar
dosya
ismi
byte sayısı
ve
programımız burada
sonlansın
bir hata
konuyla
evet
şimdi sırasıyla
ne yapacağımızı
bir
konuşalım
tabii ki
arkadaşlar
dosyayı okuma
modunda açacağım
okuma modunda
dosyayı açacağım
dosyadan
byte byte
okuma yapacağım
arkadaşlar
okuduğum
byte'ları
şu
ismi
uzantısı
para olan
dosyaları
yazacağım
yalnız burada
bir şeye
dikkat
bir
işte
kesinlikle
burada
bütün dosyaları
hem yazma amaçlı
dosyayı
hem okuma amaçlı
binary modda
açmam
gerekiyor
burada
text modunda
açmam
mesela
windows işletim
sisteminde
problem
oluşturacak
nerede
problem
oluşturacak
mesela
26'ın oğlu
arkadaşlar
karakteri
okuduğunda
doğrudan
e-off
muamelesi
yapacak
şimdi buradaki
algoritmik tarafı
aslında son derece
basit
bütün problemlerde
bir
dosya isimlerini
oluştururken
stud format
kütüphanesini
kullanmıyorsam
tahmin edin
bu dosya isimlerini
oluşturmak için
neden faydalanmam
gerekiyor
Alihan Bozkır
cevap
o string stream
format kütüphanesini
kullanmıyorsam
dosya ismini
elde etmek için
en kolay yol
o string stream
sınıfını
oluşturmak
bu bir
iki
arkadaşlar
algoritmik kısmında
sadece şurada
bir hata yapma
ihtimali var
dosyaya
şu değeri
chunk
diyelim
İngilizce'de
bu
chunk kadar
ya da chunk
size
chunk kadar
byte
yazdığım zaman
dosyanın
birini kapatıp
yeni dosyayı
açmam
lazım
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
arkadaşlar
onu da
yapmanın yolu
en basit yolu
mesela
is open
fonksiyonunu
kullanmak olabilir
yani
aynı dosya
nesnesini
kullanıp
aynı
off stream
nesnesini
kullanıp
dosyanın
açık mı
kapalı mı
olduğunu
daha doğrusu
dosyayı
kullanılmakta
olan bir dosya
olup olmadığını
sınayabilirim
hadi şimdi
birlikte
yazalım
arkadaşlar
off stream
başlık dosyasını
da dahil ettim
şimdi
önce
okuma amaçlı
dosyayı
açmam
gerekiyor
o yüzden
if stream
sınıfını
kullanacağım
arkadaşlar
stut
if stream
ifs
ve zaten
birinci
komut satıra
argümanı
arkadaşlar
yani
bir indeksi
komut satıra
argümanı
dosyanın
ismi
dolayısıyla
birinci parametreye
argv1
ikinci parametreye
okuma işlemi
yapacağım
ilave sadece
binary
modda
açılması için
stut
ios'un
binary
flagini
argüman olarak
geçiyorum
dosya
açılamadıysa
ip
arkadaşlar
değil
ifs
yani
operator
logical
not
fonksiyonu
programı
yine
sonlandırayım
bir hata
efranda yine
hata mesajı
vereyim
hata hakkında
stut
crr
efendim
cannot
open
çok Türkçe
yazıyorduk
o zaman
ne diyeceğiz
dosyanın ismi
argv1
dosyası
açılamadı
yine programı
sonlandırayım
return
farklı bir kod vereyim
şimdi
nelere ihtiyacım var
arkadaşlar
bir kere
şu
chunk değerini
kullanmam
gerekiyor
dolayısıyla
o bir yazı
olduğu için
yazıdan
sayıya
dönüştürmek
için
ya c'den
gelen
auto-e
fonksiyonu
ya da
c++'ın
kendi
fonksiyonlarını
kullanabilirsiniz
burada
auto-e
kullanmamam
için
asla
bakarsanız
hiçbir
neden
yok
işte
bugün
soru vardı
şimdi
c'nin
standart
kütüphanesindeki
fonksiyonlarda
c++'ın öz malı
gibi
kullanılabiliyor
dolayısıyla
işimize geliyorsa
mesela
bu arada
başlık dosyasına
dikkat
stdlib
başlık dosyasına
bildirildiği
için
c
stdlib
olarak
ne yaptım
arkadaşlar
include
ettim
şimdi
size t
ya da
int
fark etmez
chunk
eşittir
std
auto-e
rgv
arkadaşlar
auto-e
yazıyı
tam sayıya
dönüştürüyordu
böylece
chunk
değerini
aldım
şimdi bu
parça
par
onları elde etmek için
dosya sayısını
bilmem gerekiyor
o yüzden
oluşturulacak
dosya sayısı
için
file count
isimli
bir değişken
tanımlayayım
değeri
0 olsun
kaç byte
yazdım
o değerinde
tutulması
gerekiyor
onun için de
ayrı bir değişken
tanımlayayım
by count
evet
file count
oluşturulmuş
dosya sayısı
byte count
da
arkadaşlar
okunmuş
yazılmış
ne sayısı
byte sayısını
temsil ediyor
şimdi
burada
şuna dikkat
ben
her defasında
aynı
upstream
nesnesini
kullanabilirim
arkadaşlar
yani
dosyayı
bu sefer
open
ve close
fonksiyonlarıyla
açıp
kapayabilirim
open
fonksiyonunu
çağırıp
yeni dosyayı
açacağım
close
fonksiyonunu
çağırıp
işim
bittiğinde
o dosyayı
kapatacağım
dolayısıyla
bir de
benim neye
ihtiyacım var
dosya ismini
oluşturmak için
stream
başlık
dosyasını
dahil ediyorum
bunu
görmüştük
benlik
üstünde
okuma
yazma
işlemlerini
o
string
stream
türünden
arkadaşlar
oss
şimdi artık
dosya ismini
oluşturmak için
bundan
ne yapabilirim
faydalanabilirim
evet
buraya kadar
anlamadığımız bir şey
var mı
tamam
chunk değerini
aldık
başka neye
ihtiyacım var
şuna ihtiyacım var
arkadaşlar
dosya ismi
şöyle gidecek ya
parça
001 par
002 par
dolayısıyla
bunun için
yazma alanı
genişliğinde
sıfır değeri
vermesi için
fil karakteri
olarak
sıfır karakterini
kullanayım
evet
bundan sonrası
basit
şimdi dosyadan
byte byte okuma yapacağım
çağrı c
while
buraya dikkat
dosya
neydi ismi
ifs
get
c
yani
bu bölünecek dosyadan
byte byte okuyor
ne zamanki
e of durumuna
gelecek
yani get
fonksiyonu
başarısız olacak
stream
fail durumuna
gelecek
operatör
bool fonksiyonu
false
değer döndürecek
ama şimdi
şöyle bir soru var
ben
hangi kadar
byte yazdıktan
sonra
dosyayı
kapatacağım
ve
arkadaşlar
yeni dosyanın
açılması
gerekiyor
değil mi
onun için
işte
is open
fonksiyonunu
kullanabilirim
yani burada
bakın
şöyle yazsam
if
offstream
nesnesini oluşturayım
oluşturdum mu
hayır
tamam onu da şurada oluşturalım
offstream
offs
is open
is in
şimdi
if
ofs
değil
ofs'nin
is
open
yani
ops
stream
nesnesine
bağlanmış
bir dosya
yoksa
o zaman
bizim
dosyayı
oluşturmamız
gerekiyor
dosyayı
oluşturmak
için de
dosyanın
ismini
oluşturmamız
gerekiyor
işte
buradaki
o
string
stream
nesnesini
o amaçla
oluşturdum
o zaman
oss
ne diyelim
parça
arkadaşlar
iomanic parçalık
dosyasını
dahil ediyorum
parametreli manipülatör
olan
set v
manipülatörünü
kullanıyorum
3 karakterlik
alana
şimdi
neyi
yazacak
file count
artı 1
öyle değil mi
ilk dosya
sıfırla
başladığım için
file count
artı 1
ondan sonra
başka ne
yazacak
nokta
par
önce
dosya
ismini
oluşturdum
arkadaşlar
hatta
bakınız
eğer bunu
döngünün
her turunda
yazarsam
onu
bellek alanını
temizlememe
gerek kalmayacak
ama şimdi
dikkat
str
fonksiyonunu
çağırdıktan
sonra
yine
str
fonksiyonunu
çağırıp
oradaki
yazıyı
boşaltmam
yani orayı
yine ilk
konumuna
getirmem
gerekiyor
evet
şimdi
ofs
str
işte benim
ofs diyorum
neydi ismi
oss
böyle tabi
kötü isimler
seçmeyeceğiz
oss
str
buradan aldığım
string
açılacak dosyanın
ismi
öyle değil mi
dolayısıyla
ofs'nin
open
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
birinci parametresine
dosyanın
ismini
geçtim
efendim
bayrak olarak da
ios'un
binariesini
geçtim
böylece
yazma amaçlı
dosyan
oluşturuldu
arkadaşlar
tabi burada
yine
kontrol
yapmakta
fayda var
if
değil
ofs
yani açma işlemi
başarısı
olmuşsa
yeni bir hata
mesajı
verdirelim
stut
crl
arkadaşlar
bunu ayrı bir
değişkenle
tutmadım
oss
str
dosyası
oluş
bir bak amaçlı
en azından
işe yarayacak
dosyası
oluşturulamadı
yine burada
programı
sonlandırayım
o zaman
arkadaşlar
ne zamanki
buraya geldi
bir dosya yok
dosyayı
oluşturdu
ve bir de
ne yapması
lazım
file count'ı
bir arttırması
lazım
file count
artı
şimdi ne yapacak
bakın bu if
aslında sadece
neyi kontrol ediyor
eğer açık bir dosya
yoksa
yazılacak
o dosyayı
oluşturuyor
ama ondan sonrası
basit
bizim ne yapmamız
gerekiyor
dosyaya tek bir
karakteri yazmamız
gerekiyor
ofs
put
arkadaşlar
c
önce
okuduğum
byte'ı
dosyaya yazdım
şimdi ne yapmam
gerekiyor
byte count'ı
bir arttırmam
gerekiyor
byte count'ı
bir arttırdım
ve
şimdi
neyi kontrol
etmem
gerekiyor
chunk kadar
karakter yazdım da
takip edebiliyor muyuz
if
byte count
mode
chunk
eşit eşit
sıfırsa
o zaman
ne yapmam
gerekir
arkadaşlar
dosyayı
kapatmam
gerekir
ofs
close
dosyayı
kapattım
ve
şuradaki
o string stream
nesnesi var ya
arkadaşlar
o
o string stream
nesnesini
ne yapmam
gerekiyor
tekrar
eski haline
getirmem
gerekiyor
öyle değil mi
evet
şurada if
teyimi
görünmüyor
şuradan bahsediyorum
şu
o string stream
nesnesinden
bahsediyorum
onun için
oss'nin
str
fonksiyonuna
null
string
geçti
aslında
kod
ana hattı
bu kadar
sadece
arkadaşlar
eğer
en son dosya
kapatılmamışsa
onun da
destraktörü
çağrıldığında
dosya
kapatılacak
yani
yaptığımız iş
aslında bu kadar
ama yapılan işin sonucunda
bir de
şöyle
bir mesaj
verelim
diyelim ki
split cout
kullanıcı
e
zaten
dosyanın
büyüklüğü
byte count
byte
ar
gv
dosyası
arkadaşlar
chunk
byte
lık
chung
byte
lık
file count
dosyaya
bölündü
evet
bu kadar
ama
bir dahaki
çarşamba günü
bu arada
kusura bakmayın
geçen çarşamba günü
gerçekten çok çok acil bir iş çıktı
hiç beklemediğim şekilde
dersi iptal etmek zorunda kaldım
normalde
hastalık dışında
dersi asla iptal etmiyorum
çarşamba günü devam edeceğiz
çarşamba günü
önce
dosyalar konusunu
bitireceğiz
sonra
araya bir iki konu daha girecek
kalan zamanımızın bir kısmını da
arkadaşlar
concurrency açlıklarına
ayıracağız
ee
şimdi
süremiz
doğduğu zaman
ben en kötü ihtimalle
şöyle yapıyorum
dersleri
video olarak
ee
anlatıyorum
yani
dersleri anlatıyorum
video
halinde
doğrudan
payıt olarak
yüklüyorum
yani
süre bittikten sonra
eksik kalan
konuları
doğrudan video olarak
yine
oraya
ee
bizim
kurs sistemine
dahil edebilirim
evet
derse katıldığınız için
teşekkür ediyorum
çarşamba günü
görüşmek üzere
herkese
iyi akşamlar diliyorum
hoşçakalın
değerli arkadaşlar
abone ol